hello hello hello hello
[Applause]
September 16th
Friday baby beautiful day
thanks everybody for being here it's a
treat a treasure
that we all came together here on this
beautiful Friday joined by Ila of course
hello Ela God bless
[Music]
oh before we get too deep sponsored by
hellofresh thank you to hellofresh dude
one right next week oh for real
damn you want to show it off
damn
okay
the boots are sick too they can't see
them but the boots are well put them put
them let's have them on the table yeah
don't hold out
oh [ __ ] I call this Stomp The tater tots
boots yeah we had those that I think I
told you to stomp on me I'll stomp on my
nuts last time yeah and call me uh call
me uh your slave that's the game hey you
said that's a cardigan or how about a
God I had a joke about it where'd it go
thank you Zach no it was a card you can
car to go have a good Friday I don't
know something like that but
thank you you can go car to have
yourselves a good old Friday
you know we got a great episode here
today
um
I guess I should just explain right off
the bat well here we've got some more HR
to get to
Ela is bringing some HR issues to the
table as well so that's going to
continue on we have c-man calling in
um everybody's favorite foot fetishist
it's been a while he's got some really
good updates for us I'd love to hear
yeah
and um a lot of good stuff
Dan is gone today hmm
he left us to go to his Best Friend's
Wedding I mean the nerve of this guy
yeah W Dan this man clearly doesn't care
about his job
but Abe's filling in how you doing there
EB uh I'm scorpion I'm feeling good I've
trained from the best so I'll be okay
look at that smile look at that big
beautiful smile that's Gabe White Club
gay but a gorgeous gorgeous smile what
are you beaming over what's what are you
so happy about Gabe
I'm having I'm having a pizza at Taco
Bell a Taco Bell Pizza a pizza yeah wait
wait wait wait yeah you're having a
pizza at Taco Bell did they bring back
the Mexican pizza
that's what it is a Mexican pizza it's
like they they turn the taco into a
pizza yummy oh [ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes delicious yeah
um that was gone for a minute and then
they brought it back huh what's up
everybody oh [ __ ] baby [ __ ] hey
a little bit of a technical difficult
the window what's wrong uh with Gabe
yeah wait wait what's happening you guys
is this not looking fine is this Ian or
a B this is of course me first time you
know uh uh sorry Gabe hold on we're
having a technical issue there you are
but it's not it's supposed to be uh just
like it's just a zoom thing isn't it
yeah we have Zach this is not a joke a b
is actually lost control of the show
uh Gabe just hang with us I can see you
like 20 times I mean we can still keep
chatting
why don't we just keep chatting Gabe as
they try to fix this it'll be
interesting
are you now now the Mexican pizza was
gone and then you know it came back is
that it was that exciting for you
it's fine it's my first time having a
Mexican pizza oh
wow so how was it for you
that's good yeah oh [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] Mexican pizza [ __ ] sit
sit my dick [ __ ]
um just hold on to check in just want to
check in on a b
but I'm looking at the stream they can't
see anything right no they could they
could see they're just seeing all of us
at once oh yeah there okay it's delayed
yeah um
excellent a b you're doing you're off to
a great start here thank you yeah well I
learned yesterday it's so Zoom it's not
like it's it's just a simple like pin
that's it Gabe is pinned and when I
pinned it is when [ __ ] went to hell
so
is it fixed now or Ian's just gonna crop
it we're gonna we're gonna work this is
fine I like this this is interesting
yeah here's a cropped version of Gabe
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah ow Mexican
pizza [ __ ]
[ __ ] my Mexican pizza baby
I like Taco Bell better than Del Taco
Del Taco oh yeah
that's a Del Taco sucks [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] Del Taco yeah [ __ ] Del Taco beer
chocolate
guys do I take one or two Allegra
[Laughter]
well Allegra [ __ ] you up if you take too
much to get you sleepy or something uh
that's not drowsy Gabe do you know I
don't want to mess that stuff up
did you get anything else or just the
Mexican pizza
just the Mexican pizza and a drink
that's about it is that enough to fill
you up I wonder if a Mexican pizza would
be enough for me
it'd be good if you're really hungry I'd
go for two go for two
Taco Bell taco
all right what are you doing this Friday
anything interesting
I'm gonna do some push-ups I'm gonna get
in [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
I heard a hundred burpees will cure your
life
it sure will yeah look into that okay
Chet hanksy that was one of the best
videos we've seen all year Chet Hanks
went to a um
we watched it uh on Wednesday he went to
a
a drug rehabilitation speech for
recovering addicts and he was just so
off the rails he started arguing with
people in the audience dissing the other
guest speakers and just he kept just
talking about burpees like he just did a
hundred burpees and that's cured
everything
but I think the tater tots would
appreciate that let's see some burpees
from the tater tots
anyway Gabe listen
there's so much to do this weekend I
hope you have a great time all right all
right you have a good one
[ __ ] in my dick [ __ ] hole
[Applause]
pissing my [ __ ] hole [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] in my open title [ __ ]
no it doesn't make too much sense
put some boogers in my eyes [ __ ] holes
yeah we love that Gabe you're my you're
my biggest fan I love you buddy okay
appreciate it
yeah [ __ ]
all right thank you everybody
[Applause]
Mexican pizza
yummy
drinking my gamer um
Citrus lemonade oh my God
I'm gonna get so jacked today these
things get me so energized like nothing
coffee doesn't energize me like this
I still wish I knew why they called Gigi
do you know why love they're called GG
but it's Gamers I think it's just their
their
juice juice
yeah that's what it means but I think
maybe they just mean it like in the
traditional just good game to every
other drink
anyway guys I should explain right at
the top everyone was expecting Howie to
be on today
um on Wednesday we went in hard Ela hard
on science oh no we and and it's not my
fault it's just when I look at him I
feel like existential dread
oh Jesus
the man has yes yeah it was bad
and we were like man I hope this doesn't
reach Howie because he's going to cancel
because Simon's technically his boss and
they're promoting right now yeah because
America's Got Talent is that Simon
Cowell's show I don't know yeah he's a
producer oh Jesus yes and they're doing
a press tour together
and they're like dude don't talk [ __ ]
about Simon dude just be safe but I was
like how can I how can I help myself
this man's a demon I mean he's just a
dick
I don't want to get back into it because
we talked about it so much
on Wednesday but have you seen pictures
of that man
me yes I think so ow his skin you know
what his skin looks like when you
microwave milk the film that's on the
top oh that's Simon Cowell
so
this is the one in particular I mean I
mean the middle I don't know if I'm
being too mean but and he's only 62.
how did people react to your uh segment
I haven't watched it yet I think some
people thought it was funny a lot of
people thought it was mean you know a
lot I think I was talking too too badly
about plastic generally Insurgent I
think I uh is plastic surgery in general
I think my mistake was I think I'm
against filler we all decided
but plastic surgery of course is totally
fine if uh interesting if you want to
get it
but anyway
um so Howie
reached out
yesterday
and he said
he got a call from Simon
she got a [ __ ] call from Simon
Juju Gigi
how we got a [ __ ] call from Simon
Cowell's people
saying I know you're trying to promote
our show and this does is the biggest
podcast in the world or at least one of
them
the number one podcast in the world that
seems like a good place to promote
Howard may I call you Howard
yet Simon cow's people
[Music]
here's Simon making the call
here's Simon right now
you shall not go on the podcast
I wish she did have a big old [ __ ]
Hood so I didn't have to see his face so
much oh come on I'm just being honest
scares me
even love
the dude said come on that the dude went
trick-or-treating he was winning prizes
for best of for best uh costume and he
wasn't even wearing anything
I'm just trying to secure this how we
interview right
it's very funny though
listen if I have to suck Sam and Kyle's
dick to get a Howie on here it's not
worth it
actually everything I just said Is A Lie
uh Howie just had to reschedule he was
very gracious about it
um how he said that something came up he
had to take care of he was very very
gracious very sweet we're besties you
guys know that and uh we were in touch
with his people and we're gonna we're
gonna schedule did you did you speak
with them Olivia we're in touch people
helping people yes they they suggested a
day where we have another guest coming
up oh no oh we can bust them yeah well
we'll see yeah yeah nothing nothing yeah
no I'm just kidding uh there's no how
he's a legend he's the sweetest man ever
uh he's a true true legend and Simon you
know for whatever it's worth did not
make the call
okay so we love that for him I think
he still has time to though
believe how nice
our podcast dude Howie that man is so
sweet oh my God
the number one podcast Simon goes what's
the biggest podcast you've had on yeah
Ethan dude that's crazy yeah finally
somebody recognize it do not want to get
canceled
anyway so that's that's that's why
Howie's not here unfortunately that we
won't get to have the crossover of c-man
and wow we all dreamed of
but yeah we're gonna have a good show
nonetheless
um so thank you Howie
we love you
uh want to give a quick shout out to my
wife uh uh who's sitting right beside me
teddyfresh.com I'm obsessed with these
uh Classics oh cool I don't want to wear
anything else it is so nice
it looks great the colors are beautiful
there's this nice wash I love the pocket
um
the wash was such a pain to do why
because it's like so many extra like
processes and then there was like anyway
development it made it more difficult
and then it cost you know costs more so
it ate up into our margins right the
water is expensive in love with it it
looks so good can you tell me how to
what kind of wash do they do on this is
it an enzyme is it a stone wash what is
happening so that means they put some
kind of chemical
in there and right it makes it look this
kind of
this like worn out it's I don't know how
to say it doesn't worn out but it's kind
of just like
faded it has a
lows it's like you left it in the sun
for three years
which is a Vibe or it's brand new it is
a Vibe and then we did this label that
is like has no color and then it it
picks up the color from the wash oh from
when you dye the shirt oh no way it
looks perfect so even dyeing it it's
like we dyed the full shirt you know so
you make the shirt first then you die
then you do the wash so then even this
was a problem because the label was
supposed to pick up the color then it
didn't then we saw it then we did figure
it out it did pick up the color in the
end but you see how she do you see how
she sweats and slaves for you guys
and then and then uh Finance people do
not love washes no because they're like
but the margin just do no wash and you
gotta go talk to a finance person about
a wash I know it's because it's like I
get it like doing a wash adds like a lot
it adds a lot okay and then you know
it's hard but and it's like it's not
very noticeable but when you wear it and
feel it it's nice yeah but anyway that's
the classics I love it I'm not wearing
anything else man it's just so good
we've got the you know this everything
we just said applies to all these the
hoodie the shorts the zip up
the pants this is a woman's pants
woman's teeth skirt and no women women
zip up oh crew neck I wish it was hot
enough I could do the crew neck so sick
dude I have the zip up on it's my
favorite jacket yes yay slay
you're wearing wait Green Oh yeah this
one yeah
that would be right here yes I'm telling
you this guy this is such a nice piece
of clothing
um also well go ahead oh sorry go ahead
the purple hoodie is one of my favorite
type of fish hoodies ever hi guys oh
yeah we sent you one okay
the purple came out with the water I
know it's like so
it's such a nice color oh thank you guys
and then these are these socks also
washed yeah oh those look so nice
so that's what I'm saying I just want to
recognize the work that they're doing
over there at Teddy fresh it is really
really high end stuff so teddyfresh.com
check out the classic collection I'm
loving it I'm loving it um next week New
Collection comes out and there's a lot
of fire pieces in that one including
that which is literally on fire
there you have it
I love you appreciate you nothing is on
fire oh actually nothing is on fire
you you just said it's on fire make up
your mind I don't know what's for that
girl
actually I must I forgot to ask Gabe
dude this is the best thing Gabe's ever
made a friend of ours
cousin is a huge friend fan of white
claw game yeah
and so she asked
our friend to ask us if no no our friend
asked us if we could get
a cameo for her cousin her dad
unfortunately passed away
and she's wrought over it and she
thought this would cheer her up as a
huge fan of White Cloud Gabe so
what we did is we paid him we booked it
because we you know we don't ask him to
work for free and he's a legend White
Club Gabe on cameo
so we booked it and then Lena what
happened so Zach did you reach out to
him reached out to him
um excuse me said put a lot of love on
this one you know we know you're great
at what you do but just you know for the
family put a little extra on it and he
sent this masterpiece
so again the context here is that her
dad passed away tragic
as that is and here's Gabe uh coming
through here
muted hold on one sec
Randy
do you have that sound bite attack I'm
sorry about your dad passed
[Music]
I mean that that's that's that's the
best thing you could ever dream to have
can you actually include you have to
react can I laugh do I cry well it's
meant to cheer him up right so I'm
assuming
can you get because he says woo
afterwards can you just I have to pull
it but yeah just yeah sorry about your
dad
when I first opened this I was like no
[ __ ] shot game did a [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
yeah woo after that but he did and he's
a legend for it white Club game on Cameo
this is the [ __ ] that you can expect
from this absolute content creation
that's some love on there baby oh I'm
sorry about your dad passed
I want to wish you the best sometimes
life doesn't go on forever everybody has
to go sometime Randy [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry
that's true actually I mean
that is true
this guy knows how to send condolences I
really mean it this is good
I mean if this doesn't cheer you up I
don't know what yeah
honestly yes great it would [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] yeah sorry about your dad died [ __ ]
baby everybody dies Someday Baby
so awesome
yo if I if we ever have a tragedy in my
life yeah I want one of these you guys
hear me you know what Gabe to eulogy
doesn't matter it doesn't matter how
tragic how profound of a loss it is I
want a white Club Cameo his eulogy is
just it's amazing oh yeah I prefer if
he's if he's the key speaker at my
funeral actually
of you guys you know you hear that put
that in the will for me
to you Randy cause you're the best yeah
you're the best because you deserve the
best [ __ ] yeah hey Randy I heard from
Abby about your dad who but who
sometimes life throws a curveball
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah ready you're the best
[ __ ] yeah cause it's Friday
Cheers ready
something Good's gonna happen to you
[ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry about your
dad passing away but
I know Randy's the best because Randy
deserves the best infected
you know what that was I thought it was
really sweet and touching I was like
good things are going to happen to you
you're the best yeah I thought that was
actually really yeah that's very sweet I
like that so there it is I mean I don't
know what's a better plug for it yeah
before we move on I just want to say I
was freaking out I thought I lost
control of the computer because I kind
of moved the mouse somehow Dan hacked
the computer damn
in the car from the car yeah to see what
was going on he figured out the problem
too Dan best producer in the game Dan is
ghost in the machine right yeah on his
cell phone it has to be I mean and let's
see Dan Cullen I want to talk to you I
guess he could have cast or uh it's just
a remote desktop controller but if he's
in a car he's in a car he's driving or
in the car while somebody else no like
the hot spot
let's get him on the phone Dan called
call I've gotta I gotta understand what
just happened all right Dan message in
the Discord if you're calling oh I'll
send them uh the when I just call him oh
I can't my phone's on Tick Tock you want
my phone yeah just call him on your
phone I'll put the speaker up to the mic
I told him a million times don't worry I
got you I got you the first thing that
came up
too at all so what was it that he had to
call him no it's it's
it's weird it's not like normal Zoom
because how we have it set up
it was basically double pinning you and
Gabe at the same time
it's a zoom error
it's it's complex hello Dan are you
watching the show right now
I was a minute ago oh my God
Dan did you just hack into Amy's
computer
technically it says computer well hack
is a strong word yeah they use Remote
Desktop to get onto it and fix the zoom
thing I saw the uh the white claw game
call oh my God excited to help him out
hello yeah um let me ask you this was
you were you on your Dan says hello were
you did you hack from your phone or like
did you what hot spot it yeah from your
phone it's just an app on my phone yeah
what
[Music]
don't let Dan near the electronics he's
gonna hack it
Dan how do you control a desktop from a
phone I don't even understand that
it's it's really I don't want to give
away secret sauce too much um because it
won't make this seem a lot less
impressive but um yeah I mean it's just
it's just a little app
all right well thank you Dan he's Ghost
in the Shell he's helping out uh AB if
you need any yeah what are you going to
be available all day if maybe needs more
help
yeah it is a long drive I'm gonna be in
a car
okay great yeah uh you hear that AB yeah
take your time Dan you know taking the
sights don't you don't need to arrive as
quick as possible
hello all right all right thanks Dan
hello he was probably cussing me out
because I didn't know that's what he was
doing and I was fighting back the mouse
for a good two minutes like freaking out
and he was pulling it one way and I'm
pulling it the other I told you yeah
I was like oh my God where the [ __ ] did
I do oh my God damn ladies and gentlemen
we got the best podcast in the game as
the best producer in the game yeah safe
he's hacking computers from his mobile
phone whatever you dance
what's that gift you're putting W Dan
with the ball dad let me see that again
come
on oh okay no problem yeah also
yesterday we had a little bit of an
experimental episode
you guys had so much fun doing the
metaverse one a few weeks ago that we
decided we're gonna do a dedicated
episode so
uh we did it it was about an hour long
went into the metaverse
you know we had we had a b jacked in
there with the third person camera
it was just to be honest I unlisted it
afterwards
uh it was just it was too chaotic you
know people are probably wondering why
we unlisted it
I think in theirs was was great moments
but on the whole it was a lot of like oh
I'm trying to join the room
we're trying to party up you know what I
mean there's a lot of
not fun stuff to watch
I do think if we edited it up it would
be great which is kind of what I want to
do in the future with those
but it was a it was a huge I mean did
you see I saw a few things on the suburb
they looked really funny like one of
them was when you I don't you were
fighting with someone or something with
the lightsaber yeah it cuts through the
gray screen and it looks so silly yeah
yeah well here let me just read this um
somebody had a today's VR episode
was 55 minutes long
we had a bait there was a baby in there
who was calling me a [ __ ] like
literally a five-year-old was like you
look like a [ __ ] you look like a [ __ ]
I love the meta babies holy crap that
was blowing my mind and then of course I
got a month banned for groping ab's
Avatar a month a month this month oh
yeah yeah but we haven't been there
though it wasn't me so it looked like me
but you were it was Dan yeah it was Dan
um
so we'll do it again but I think what
we'll do is pre-record it
edit it up
edited it up I say edited edited is that
funny kind of weird huh say edited Arabs
always say I don't know but Arabs always
say edit it out edited it edited that
why do they say that I don't know this
way it flows I think or something to do
with how Arabic language I don't know
edited a doubt
not all Arabs obviously just for the
idiots Lena are all Arabs walking around
saying edited it out if they have a
strong accent yeah that's usually how it
comes out edit it out but that's what
I'm saying what's that what's wrong with
what you're one of us oh I don't
understand what's wrong with saying edit
it out
edited out
because that's how it is
yeah edit it out no no edited edited
like oh it's edited yeah yeah there you
go this is a crazy word edited edit it
out edit it edited it out is that crazy
word how's nobody talking about editing
it it's like nuts try you guys try
saying it
everybody at home is saying edited right
now edit it edit it out and
cut it out
but yeah it was fun so shout out
everyone who saw it if you guys really
want to see it it's unlisted we can drop
the link in the
link is still up on Twitter oh yeah so
go to our our Twitter
HD podcast you couldn't find the link
there if you really want to watch it
so
um
did you see uh one of the Queen's guards
fainted during her procession I guess
she's lying in state they call it which
is when her rotting body sits there for
weeks
four weeks weeks yeah or days
they just and they come and like
pay their respects to a rotten corpse
Dan said the line to get in one of the
days was 30 hours oh my God yeah is
there smell how do they prevent a smell
this is a decomposing body I was
thinking though it's a 12-day period of
national morning where the queen
is out he's in a box I don't know what
they do about let me look at what they
do with her body I'm just curious does
it stink in there they probably stuff it
let's see like with hay or something hey
how's that going to prevent it from
stinking well you take out all the
stinky you think they disemboweled the
queen and stuffed her with hay so she's
a mummy yeah what they made it like a
[ __ ] you're saying they made
Taxidermy of the queen yeah of course
they I I genuinely think they did their
bodies kept for the first three days
three days that's getting a stink yeah I
know
um
usually now they drain the body and they
add some sort of uh injection to fill
what was in there like the blood and
artificial stuff they put in
formaldehyde or some [ __ ] okay you're
saying
but okay so so there's they have a way
of not making it rotting just put some
according to love straw is stuffed
inside she's a scarecrow actually now
either that or it's like a fridge in
there oh it could be refrigerated that's
what's going on it's refrigerated a
cooling casket yeah her ass is Frozen On
Ice I think you can still see Vladimir
Lenin's body to in um
Mausoleum well they have it for all the
North Korean leaders too
tomorrow what their what do you could
see their body yeah they embalm them
yeah they mummify them and put them in
glass cases for people wait what wait
pull up a photo of that like if you type
in Kim Kim Jong ill was that his father
Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-il he's laying in
like the head of
Pyongyang or some [ __ ] wait I gotta see
what that looks like wow I need to see
this disemboweled
maybe they stuffed it with rice
I don't think we could just show this
but I could show me is it that bad yeah
it looks like it's like awake like have
you ever been to a wake it's a way yeah
I actually let me see drop it in Discord
I'll decide if I just want to show it
what Jewish people don't do that stuff
right
the Jews don't do open open caskets
I've never been to one so I maybe not no
you're right here bro yeah so it's very
so let's take a look here oh that's it
it's it's not very
it's not that bad yeah yeah it's just
him laying down covered in a red blanket
there's a casing see I I can't tell if
oh wait I can go next here we go let's
see
all of his like organs have been
stripped out
yeah it's not that bad
but so but this guy's been like
freeze-dried like a [ __ ] like a piece
of beef jerky at this point
somebody just wrote in the chat it's a
bad time to be eating jerky
yo but this he looks really good though
don't you think
I mean he's been dead for what
10 years now
yeah for his age it looks great they
look awesome that smells good that's
insanely good the wax what happened to
this poor guys
he was the original I think he was just
the pilot well it's I think Stalin's or
Stalin buried
wait why is this thing like crashing and
it looks destroyed uh full of Communism
my friend he was the beta test right
there
this is very interesting they're still
is Stalin still you could go chill with
Stalin
that one I don't know about who's saving
Stalin's body I thought everybody hated
him
somebody loved him look at all these
flowers
Vladimir Putin Vladimir
oh that's super interesting so shout out
to Queen let's get her ass on display
[ __ ] it this could be a huge tourist
attraction
I say get her ass on display now
she lived for the people prove it
good morning my Queens of tick tock and
and Philip or Charles you're next
your ass isn't glass too dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
fill that bag up with the Queen's organs
right now uh my mom is on vacation right
now and she just texted me she said she
went and saw the queen she did yeah she
waited she waited in the lion yeah she
said she waited two hours oh that's not
too bad yeah yeah not not too bad it's
longer to get on like Splash Mountain
yeah I was just gonna say interestingly
people are more interested in Splash
Mountain than seeing the queen they got
like a fast pass yeah the genie passed
the Lizzy pass I'm reading Lizzy in a
box
uh she does say she had to get a
wristband and then came back later so it
is sort of like a genie system oh she
did get a fast pass wow you got to pay
that the people take photos like are you
allowed to take a picture uh she said
that you could not take pictures inside
okay um and it was a closed casket and
they had a flag on top and a crown
it was close so she doesn't see her this
is the casket
yeah nobody okay so we don't know if
she's actually in there or not there
might not even be a body so that's yeah
I I thought they were seeing the body
and I thought that's kind of creepy yeah
no she's just in there
um and and did she say anything else how
was that experience for her was it a
powerful
the powerful
uh she said that it was a beautiful
cathedral it went by very fast
got to chat with people in line wasn't
bad at all okay
why would she give it on Yelp I wonder
I'm uh
mom if you're seeing this we want the
Yelp review what rating would she give
it uh actually I guess she missed it but
Gabe what clock Gabe was there to you
YULA eulogize her actually
[ __ ] baby
I'm sorry the queen died [ __ ] baby I'm
sorry about your dad passing away yeah
so
um that's the queen everybody
I still start to interrupt we have to go
to an ad break dude wow somebody
actually told me at the 30 minutes oh
come on come on I gotta says bad habit
of letting me go way too [ __ ] long
because I never keep track of myself
I gotta defend my boy here literally he
does he's looking for the right time to
do it I feel like you guys there's no
right time you just got to tell me so
because
sometimes it's like an hour and a half
in and then I'm like dude like the
sponsor gets pissed off
then we have to do a free read for them
or some [ __ ]
my mom just texted me she said 10 out of
10. great funeral oh okay cool cool
there you have it Trip Advisor says
great
attractions mom no stink was there a
stink did you ask her well it's in the
clothes
box
if it's not pro it's probably not like
her hermitically sealed or whatever
probably a few stink particles come
through there hermetically yeah you know
when it says like it's like fully sealed
there is her there's a word for that it
starts with the h
Dan would know if he was here
he would
let me type it yeah Oh I thought I got
it right hermetically sealed oh wow come
on guys okay I never heard that I
apologize hermetic ceiling's a process
of creating a container of some sort
that is airtight
airtight
thank you
uh speaking of airtight
hellofresh
It's Gonna Leave You Breathless
because it is that good
Cooper Troopers around the world
are loving hellofresh because it's
nutritious it's easy to make best of all
it's delicious love hellofresh guys
tremendous offer to for our listeners
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
the trips to the grocery store and count
on hella fresh to make home cooking fun
easy and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit
did you know that um you can actually
save money buying hellofresh is 25 less
expensive than takeout and it's even
cheaper than grocery store shopping you
don't even have to think about it um
you know I there's so many bold points
here of great stuff trying to find a
good one
um dishes look so good no I'm yeah and
they're like perfectly balanced meals
you know
uh enjoy the freshest fall flavors every
hell of fresh recipe includes ripe just
picked produce that travels from the
farm to your door
in less than a week
I love it so much they basically
pre-portioned they measure it out
perfectly beautiful fresh ingredients
they include this really wonderful uh
information card with information about
all the food the dish and how to cook it
step by step it's really a no-brainer
and it's fun for people experienced or
beginner alike and the food just turns
out great every time
here's this incredible offer go to
hellofresh.com after dark16 and use the
code after dark 16 for 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
that's free food
people say there's no such thing as a
free lunch
hellofresh says [ __ ] those people
my words not theirs
go to hellofresh.com after dark 16 and
use the code after dark 16 for 16 free
meals
uh thank you thank you thank you to
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
yes let's go let's go
it's hellofresh okay
[Music]
anyway about the queen
um
yes so she died idiot
anyway she's dead yeah she's dead so
anyway here's one of her that's kind of
a nice thing though like I could see if
if this was um
a big leader that I grew up me admiring
like you then
um it's kind of nice for everybody to be
able to go there and say
pay their respects yeah yeah
I think so yeah
yeah it's nice
I mean we do have that in America when
like if a president dies ex-president
they have like a huge public
funeral it's a funeral there's not it's
not like yog do the
walk around the coffin but
people show up but anyway
here's one of her royal guards
uh dropping the ball here a little bit
very serious work here
okay get it together man
very serious work there bud I think this
smells getting to him I think that's
what it is
because he's close
just imagine stand up yeah
um
so
he's basically wobbling
the man is wobbling
and oh my god oh
it's a little bit scary about that is he
almost fell on his bayonet
he's got like a big ass knife at the tip
of his
oh is he holding like is he holding a
pole arm or a gun
I don't think they're they're not going
to be able to put up a good defense with
these like sticks like a fortnight
pickaxe
you know what do you think happened to
him
I think he was either standing too long
I mean he's pretty old either standing
too long or the smell I honestly think
it was the smell
when your knees are locked and they're
straight for a long time if you don't
keep them bent or if you like bend them
out of nowhere after a long time the
like blood flow can cause you to faint
I I was very worried about him I wanted
to see if he was okay and I couldn't
find anything but I found a lot of
explanations
um I mean he could have also just been
overwhelmed with grief
he lost his Queen
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was perfect Zach why you do that
now it looks like I was just laughing at
this guy falling
yeah I mean that's fine I think he's
fine what I want to know is like like
what if you got to take a [ __ ] or take a
pic or a diaper I mean you're standing
there for what 12 hours no they sub out
they don't stand there for 12 hours they
they rotate
just go on the lawn Zach
yeah they just piss on the [ __ ]
coffin dude yeah oh my God
so anyway that was fun shout out to the
queen God bless her soul too soon going
yeah
too soon taken from us Queen Elizabeth
II
speaking of the queen liver King
actually visited
a Buckingham Palace to pay his respects
this man is a monster dude
this man went from the 911 memorial
shirtless now it's a Buckingham Palace
shirtless what does he do how does he do
that what are the logistics of this man
what's up Burger King holy [ __ ]
shoot him you know what
I authorize deadly force
is this a Vibe or
I don't know I mean did you hear what he
said he said I'm here it's the liver
King oh tell the kids
I'm here
that's kind of funny it's me
it is kind it's kind of a Vibe I don't
know it's such a maniac why did you
unmatch me the guy is constantly
traveling across the world shirtless
with [ __ ] weights Queen loved to work
out man so you know just paying your
respects she was a mad lifter bro dude
she benched like 350 it was crazy
oh [ __ ] so there you go um everyone's
paying their respects even uh the liver
King so shout out it's me yes
um also you guys may have noticed that
we've been really enjoying this ninja
hello sound bite
um if this did you have you heard this
go ahead play that Zach
hello well so I have been hearing you
guys use it but I haven't seen the
original origin of it I didn't know this
was from Ninja and actually what's even
crazier is that it's from Ninja shouting
us out why oh really yes
say hello to the H3 podcast hello
Ethan Klein boy he's over there the crew
yeah by the way the audio is messed up
dude
incredible hello
hello hello hello
there's something inexplicably catchy
about that is over there the crew
because when I first heard that hello
hello I immediately liked it without
even knowing the content podcast hello
hello hello hello hello
hello hello
I can't do it hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
you got a deal hello hello
hello
also you guys if you watched on
Wednesday you know we had a huge HR
conflict
a b was upset that love posted an
unflattering photo of him
on to Twitter
and of course the subreddit has been
very gracious and
yeah right I'm sorry A B Flocka now this
one's this is this one edited
I know that's original
yeah there's a lot of posts about it oh
they even edited your avatar edited
edited
they even edited your avatar the buck
teeth that's that was unknown
this is my favorite
this is my [ __ ] favorite bro oh my
God this is for sure what you would look
like I never thought it looked Middle
Eastern until I see a lot of these edits
I look like some of my uncles
if you gained like how much do you weigh
uh 175. yeah if you gain 100 pounds this
is what you would do
he looks nice
yeah he looks like a friendly guy yeah
he's like accurate or something I don't
know
uh this one why did they just post the
original one I don't know why people
keep this they did they made my teeth
bigger
and my eyes more off-centered seriously
yeah I can't tell
I don't know why Amy hates this photo so
much he looks cute I I have something to
add to the HR segment actually today
when we get into it we can go right into
it after this it just came in it just
came to me yeah okay Lena thoughts on uh
on beautiful uh I'm sorry but it's so
funny and in that first um shot that you
showed actually in the original post
they have his eye rotating it's in
motion yes
oh
has your perception of Av change
permanently now that you know that he's
has is uh took a subpar photo no no it's
not like that it's so fun to see though
uh maybe anything if anything it makes
the real a b way more handsome because
you see the contrast you know thanks
love
yeah I don't know what you're talking
about this [ __ ] like is this edited or
not I don't know this is uh what's his
name Lena what's the guy's name
Christopher Walker walk no Steve Buscemi
a mesh of all of it yeah it's like the
deep fried meme of him this one is so
good
um wow that burrito looks amazing my
compliments to the chef the chef
[Applause]
that's a good one
AV did that he killed Frieza this one's
fine you look cool in this one what
upsets me about that one I love Dragon
Ball Z that would have been a really
cool if I didn't look like that what
your face what
come on can't wait for the HD Halloween
uh yeah you're gonna use will buyers
yeah well
this one honestly Evie doesn't even look
that bad in this photo and that's what I
keep trying to tell you baby looks
totally fine
yeah these little subtle ones like just
make my neck small wait what do you mean
subtle it's not edited
oh my neck doesn't exist
what just happened uh Dan's hacking you
down to my [ __ ] computer
yeah uh here's one this is uh this is
really exciting actually find the lock
um
a little preview for our Halloween
special there
that's the same guy that's done all the
cool things such a talent yeah shout out
which is your favorite here uh AV
the one on the bottom left because it
looks like my grandfather that I never
met but it does look like him did what
did he pass when you were young is that
what happened huh did he pass when you
were young
um no my dad fled Lebanon and came here
and he doesn't even remember his dad he
went to go visit him when he was older
and like a week before he took his trip
in his 20s he passed away oh yeah oh
that's yeah that's tragic uh can you
play the Gabe sound bite for that uh
yeah
sorry about your
thing away [ __ ] yeah yeah my condolences
about that [ __ ] yeah
um that's all of them so this is a oh no
no it's not all of them there's actually
more AB
s this is pretty interesting this is the
he's stealing it guys yeah
definitely seeing the resemblance mm-hmm
there's a lot okay so let's I actually
prefer the ones where I look
overweight compared to the normal one
because you know that's not you probably
feels safer maybe yeah so let's do the
HR segment since this is a perfect
lead-in
um this all came from the HR segment
by the way this was the same guy what's
his name again find the lock you'll find
the lock we gotta make this for everyone
to Hype the Halloween oh that's a great
idea by the way we did this yesterday
either you're Nancy
is that okay oh I'm Nancy again because
I've heard that I was also joyous at
some point
whichever
I'm they all made me Dustin
but then they then they voted me as Papa
oh did we do a vote for Ila I don't
think we did but I think everyone just
accepted Nancy it wasn't a contention
yeah are you okay with Nancy
it's a good one right yeah and then do
you think I'm Dustin or Papa
I saw the Dustin in there but then now
that you say papa that's pretty cool
Papa 's you they got Papa that man's a
psychopath
um
[Music]
if you had to pick a stranger things
character
who do you think I most am like who
would I be I just feel like uh visually
like it's easier to imagine the Dustin
one
but
like just colors and I don't know the
curly hair it's just easier but I I like
the papa one more what do you like about
Papa
it's just like a strong character these
are psycho but I like muffins I think I
decided that I'm gonna go as the
demogorg we decided that's Epic full
makeup everything let me finish
yeah but this all came from the HR so
let's finish up where we started of
course
on Wednesday we had lots of complaints
filed from people in the office members
of the crew about other members of the
crew and it was my job as the HR
representative to resolve these issues
we didn't get to finish them
Zach actually had a problem with me he
wanted to bring up and
I have one with you too great it's not
on the list
great okay well Zach um it is a little
bit of a conflict of interest I am your
boss your HR
and your God but go ahead I guess say
that you criticize me I dare you well I
put all the information in um
documentation you know if we ever take
this chord or some [ __ ] oh my God okay
so Zach has brought a PowerPoint into HR
wow well we put in the effort
well you got started I don't know uh
we're gonna have to ask yeah where am I
oh not at the beginning
now
[Music]
okay so this is very unorthodox
yeah you know everything you know you
just tell you just tell me next slide
when you want okay okay so why I'm not
Penguin brand by Zach Lewis what's that
got to do with me
you're gonna have to see the PowerPoint
dude so here are examples of I am Joker
brain
you know it's been working here four
years
you can see all the examples the art
the face masks but you bought this face
mask
so
I'm just saying you can't
that's like you saying your Joker brand
I mean I get that there's two pieces of
fan art that's fine but like you bought
this
you know what I mean I don't see your
boy okay next slide
[Laughter]
other examples there's Ian supporting me
um a b as well
that photo by the way
um
we went to go pick something up at like
FedEx or something and I was like oh
shoot I forgot my mask and that's
literally the only type of mask that
Zach has in his car and I'm like I
really gotta put this on to go in here
he's like yeah this is all I got and
then what's interesting is that he has
more than one yeah you get them in a
pack of three
next slide
sure next slide
here Zen AB supporting me CAM beautiful
fan art I am the Joker okay next
right how is Av supporting there yeah
how was you that's a good question how
is Amy supporting you here he's in a
picture with me okay ABD are you
supporting him is that what's going on I
I I'm not even he cropped me out I'm not
my full costume's not even in it if you
want me to support you at least show off
my whole costume it's a yes or no
question yeah sure buddy okay there we
go okay all right all right next so uh
just because I only ate a little bit of
the Hot Chip does not justify me losing
the Joker brand name prove myself
followed the mentality in Creed of
anything for the show for the last four
years and I feel I've proven my worth
just because there was one task I did
not complete to not justify being
penguin brained is more Joker to not eat
spicy food because the Joker has too
much to accomplish in that day and not
have to be stuck on the toilet [ __ ]
your brains out I saw comments that
persuaded me that were like you know
Joker would have eaten that chip you
would have put thrown in his mouth and
he would have never thought about it no
he'd have one of his goons Do It um no
he wouldn't
see that what do you think about this I
am very very caught up on the the fact
that there's only one dot here after the
word chip
here which doesn't make sense in that
sentence wait this one dot yeah
and just because I only ate a little bit
of the hot chip that's right the grammar
is exact
Hot Chip does not there's this isn't a
complete sentence that might be helping
his case I I think that's intentional
no language arts is not my specialty and
may I joke her brain does one word
correct does that say joker Bryant
I can't believe that's how you spell
brain
like I said language arts
next slide well hold on we haven't even
read the whole damn oh we did but see I
think the problem here uh Zach is that
penguin is not bad it's an honor but
that's fine but I I that's not me it's
not an insult to say that your penguin
brain do you understand I I completely
accept that
um but I'm not penguin afraid and I
highly disagree with it
yeah I mean this is a good point
Joaquin Joker would have eaten the chip
Jared Leto would not have eaten the
chips so let me ask you this which Joker
are you
um I'm like the Jack Nicholson mix with
the Joaquin
nice we're mixing and matching Jokers
now yeah dude it's one mentality that's
what I love you know
next slide please sure
so I've provided some examples of why I
am Joker brain and my proving myself
anything for the show throughout the
years
just some quick short clips
uh thank you by the way to a uh a pizza
Olivia backdrop fund wow
that's a very close stately donation
thank you so much hello hello all right
well here's Zach um and what's the date
on this can somebody
tell me when was this published
sometime in 2019. it's been a minute I'd
say it's been a while since uh it goes
through the years Ethan
got it oh
okay all right I think you might even
just get two if I'm being honest
if I do this I won't take your money
doing this for the show no I'm gonna pay
you look so young he's so crazy looking
back at these videos
oh my god when I look back
you you and Ian which you guys were the
first employees Dan too you know your
kids you've got to look at these photos
it's crazy
can somebody Source some I want to pull
them up it's really shocking
yeah I mean this is from August
2019 Zach it's been a minute since but
that five seconds you just played I'll
play I'll keep playing no no I just want
I want to make a board five seconds you
just played proving you did not have to
pay me for the task
I would have done it for my loyalty for
myself I know that mm-hmm
you earn it man
can we open this yeah this is
there we go how does it smell take a
smell
is this the good stuff is this the
mayonnaise of choice the regular smegula
the real man oh you got the oh he got us
the Kroger [ __ ] you guys the store
Brandon
all right so cheers
there we go
you definitely getting this was back
when Zach was the heartthrob yep many
years ago
he quickly said yep
the pain is still
still felt
oh my gosh there's one
dance the one here of Dan is really
shocking where's Zachary
look at Dan yeah he looks so young what
happened Dan look at yourself
I still look like a fat idiot no around
my faces
I'm gonna be honest this photo you guys
kind of all look the same to me a little
bit this isn't this is yeah this isn't
that good well you got to go in the
podcast I think Olivia and take screen
uh take stills from it you know
um
yeah this this one's not good either
remember we're covered
yeah so um
okay you want me to keep watching this
you don't keep watching
that one's another example of I [ __ ] on
a lawn you you don't I said you've never
done that have you [ __ ] in a flower bed
I've shot on some dude lawn before why
did you do that okay so it's when I was
in school and it was well we've all
heard this story a million times and I
want to tell you this is
something that happened a long time ago
what Joker brain have you done for me
lately well if you keep finishing the
slide all right do I need to go next
yeah I get like five bites
it's just examples so go to that I said
you've never done that have you [ __ ] in
a flower okay I'm trying
there we go so they're a mayonnaise uh I
took a [ __ ] Mayo here we go you guys
ready a little here so what's the date
on this yes sir Halloween 2020. yes what
have you done for me joke or brain
delayed Lisa
these are years old man
this one's recent what was the date on
this one that one's in 21.
[Music]
what month
um hi it was like right before we moved
in here I believe it was meant exactly
the sound line so it's been over a year
since you've done Joker brain you've
gone Joker brain for me
today in Southern California today I'm
going to show you why I am wow that was
yeah but anyway you take them you take a
bath which you know we appreciate that
you did that
[Music]
this feels nice yeah and then this one
of course was the iconic uh
Big Ed came in and
oh that was a different thing but here
we go are you guys ready so is it just
more
uh yeah I just point out my laugh also
um I was a
class one narcissist the man is
look this is this I'm just showing
evidence here you're a class one
narcissist yeah we proved that I'm the
craziest ones off the channel
the narcissism scale narcissism scale
um
it's faded who can I say was crossfaded
if not Zach nobody went for the damn
thing you know man I'm on zilly zonka
and booze right now but zilizanka just
comes from my my brain right that's
that's the mental illness pass that
bottle I'm ready to turn up dude that
bottle is gone
yeah that was that was good that was
good Zach you're right there was drunk
uncle at Thanksgiving wait that I feel
like that was great
that was powerful that was good I want
to see that again it's that bottle I'm
ready to turn up dude that bottle's gone
it's not completely gone
oh my god oh I'm sorry Zach but I
remember a comment saying Zachary me of
a girl in Middle School who takes one
drink and then lets everyone know that
they're that they're drunk the whole
time did I not drink that whole bottle
he was drunk
okay here we got some good ones look
thank you Olivia this is [ __ ] amazing
was this the first shipment we ever
showed again and that might be that is
yo that's crazy don't tell me that's not
nuts yeah we had this whole gag going on
in the very beginning of the show where
we would never show Ian on camera we
never showed his face
what do you think about that Ian and Sam
too
I don't know who that is right he looks
so different yeah little kid dude Ian's
getting younger somehow I feel like
I feel like he looks younger I don't
think he looks younger no it just looks
so different
didn't Ethan just call me like an old
[ __ ] like three days ago yeah I don't
know oh for the mustache yeah no I think
you look good I think you you've evolved
look at the light in this young man
fresh face Trail wow Batman that man was
making power points
you know he was uh
doing other stuff exciting
exciting times and this was what like
only five years ago five years really
age you
sorry Jesus I'm just saying it does I
wonder why look at Dan this man had a
[ __ ] head of air you get a riddle to
each other this man had a full head of
hair when he started
I gotta get one of him like head on
Olivia if you can
he was vaping like a [ __ ] Maniac yeah
he had this massive like modded Vapor
yeah
and he would just rip that all show so
hard
and I think he was getting messed up on
the Nick thinking she was like sweaty
and like it was just like constantly a
vape Cloud falling over
those were the Vibes back then though
weren't they
used to arrive at the podcast office and
it would just smell like The Vape yeah
cotton candy yeah that one
here is how Zach imagined the spicy chip
challenge going I'm just gonna dip my
toes Murray
Church
um
I have other old photos uh here is
what is this one that's an edit
but I found that funny with the ELO one
I'm not Eli Dan why did you send this
one Olivia she looks so young oh really
young but like in terms of
you just look it's early podcast you
know you look this same to me your face
totally looks the same but your whole
style is different it I think you're
also maybe wearing a costume yeah sure
yeah this one is I was the CEO costume
hell yeah but um yeah you know I used to
uh
just show up and then I think I kind of
started trying some makeup oh yeah
looks doing my hair a little
um
we'll get back to your uh PowerPoint
here in a sec Zack you know
you can complain about this to him if
you want oh Zach this one's so good this
was right when you started too Isaac
um look at this baby
look at this sweet child brought some
wait how five years ago how old were you
when you joined were you even 20. I was
uh 20 21 I'm gonna be 25 next week
[Music]
oh yeah next week yep
happy birthday bud thank you
I'd buy you a Rolex but you already have
one I can always have another no that's
just that's just Overkill
yeah I guess now you gotta find one of
me Olivia me skinny skinny
[Music]
really cool though all right Zach so uh
I guess you're you you're complaining
about something right yeah the laugh
Zach's Indian's personality tests are
off the chart oh yeah we did a
narcissism test and Ian scored zero this
man doesn't even exist
[Music]
that was pretty bizarre like how like
the guy who did the test was like I have
never seen this in my life you have no
ego Ian how's that possible you have you
scored a zero you don't even exist
that checks out
Sam does that make sense to you that he
got a zero
which one was it for ego we were doing a
narcissism test and they basically
basically on a scale it's normal to get
something like you know between like 10
and 15 or whatever Zach was off this
charts narcissism and Ian got the mirror
he had no points I mean I wouldn't say
that Ian's like at all narcissistic I
don't know I guess it checks out but it
a zero is kind of crazy that's right for
anyone yeah the guy's like you don't be
a narcissist let's see who scored oh my
God your hair looks great I love that
look
[Music]
it was cool should I do it again I
thought it was really cool it was fun I
loved it no I like I like it a lot I
think you should go for it if you liked
it
yeah you rocked it all right it's a lot
of work but I know but it's fun wait why
is it a lot of work well as soon as the
hair grows you gotta decide like do you
keep up with the roots or not like my
hair right now so is that what you meant
you got yeah it's like two colors you
got to keep it up so if you want to keep
it up Lena tells me to keep it up also
getting to style your hair is more
difficult like I used to before this I
used to wear it natural a lot like just
let it air dry and it would be fine and
then once I bleached it it was like my
hair was like sponge and when it's wet
it feels weird and then when it dries
it's like
like a perfect thing I thought your hair
looked great during that season
we love that season
oh
it turns out
the second highest score with a 28 out
of 40 is
[Music]
oh and then Trisha was the only one that
beat you right correct yeah
that's so funny this was a great segment
this was a great segment I love these
two
you know we had a little mini beef with
Drew or not me but the fans got angry at
him because he was like
but Drew was a good guest you know
if we could have him on to uh
retest Ian or something make sure his
heart works
anyways you don't have to watch the full
clip but um next slide please
uh yeah I'm not done here uh I'm
enjoying this it turns out
the second highest score with a 28 out
of 40 is yeah
Zach you narcissistic piece of [ __ ] we
[ __ ] knew it okay all right
okay mini tick tocks my friend okay I
you just think you're so good looking
don't you no I I'm deeply insecure about
myself and you think you should get all
the girls don't you no no no no I I the
truth be told I'm deeply insecure about
myself is that true you seem very
confident um I mean I think like I'm
anyone that insecurities and you know
Zach you [ __ ] dude yeah
you definitely [ __ ] I I I will say I
have horrible body dysmorphia that's the
one thing that always [ __ ] with me yeah
that's a problem all right next slide
next slide please so let the evidence
show I will do anything for the show and
I am Joker Brandon I'm the Joker baby
no right some similarities oh now you're
coming at me yeah some similarities
between Ethan and the Penguin not making
any claims
just pointing out some similarities you
are making claims I'm not making it's in
the text just exactly stand behind it
dude yeah just stand behind it why are
you gonna be like Oh I'm not do I mean
you are making claims just own it what
the hell is going on here all right go
ahead what do you want to say
um can you cut back to that okay thank
you why did you crop it like this I I
don't know man just roll with it
um
so here uh some comparisons to you and
Oswald cobblepot
next slide please
you want to unpack this a little bit for
me I'd let the evidence show itself
you think that
damn this was a recent one of me too
yeah that angle is bat rough on me boy
but I will say you are looking thin you
you have you're looking svelte I'm
penguin in recovery that being said I'll
have fully admit that the body
the body's there the face is there I
want to be penguin
the years man
I could never take that role from you
dead air
I couldn't see the slide there we go
another comparison
another comparison picture yeah yes yes
yes okay
um next slide please
okay so here's some more comparisons
Ethan loves fish that is not true so so
far it's a lot about appearance
as far as well also food nutrition you
know penguin loves penetration
um is that what you call what I do
nutrition because Joker brand was we
weren't looking at appearances like yeah
it was more of a
a mental state
no but he's just calling me fat
basically yeah
what I'm trying to say I'm saying you
like fish
yeah the fika fish that makes me die
when I eat it okay it looks like you're
pointing at it you're enjoying it you
know it's a good time okay fair enough
penguin likes cold things
okay okay
Isaac Ethan likes ice
oh my God very interesting a little bit
uh
little loose on the interpretation there
but I'll follow along how are we feeling
about this uh PowerPoint versus like
ab's PowerPoint oh my God there's so
many comments here as far as like the
crops some things have like
space from the border and some some
things are cut off completely
I liked it on to be honest I thought it
was about you
certainly started a long conversation
too right but I'm not trying I'm not
trying to disabase PowerPoint why you
gotta pit why you got to put them
against each other I'm not trying to get
in trouble here did you mention maybe I
was just
commenting on Zach's PowerPoint yeah
people I guess I didn't like av's
PowerPoint
no comment oh
I have a poll going and Zach is uh
looking pretty good so guys this is the
definitive if you guys want to hear your
get your voice heard Zach
is he Joker brand or penguin brain get
your votes in it's quite close quite
close actually 52 Joker brained 48
Penguin brand it is very very very close
so if you have an opinion about this the
results are binding Zach as you know
with these balls
I'm well aware
do you accept that The Binding results
of this bulls act I will because I
believe in a democracy okay okay so you
guys hear that get your votes in
ah he said he was said
I mean Ian how do you rate that
PowerPoint
um
I think he got his point across you
definitely did
uh it must have been good because
I thought he was gonna get decimated in
this poll and he's not he's holding it
down wow I want to thank the audience
but it's not closed it's not closed but
we do have 8 000 votes okay it's still
holding steady my goodness two to forty
eight everyone out there to believe we
didn't close it in the Joker Church hold
on my Academy Award acceptance speech
please uh exactly somebody should lay
down
while he's
doing his speech like like
Jimbo Kimball
how is the poll not moving I mean this
is incredible oh actually
went in his favor you know what the
audience always votes for whatever they
want okay thank you except for me thank
you everyone I love you from the bottom
of my heart welcome to the Joker church
we are all loved here we all laugh we
all do crazy [ __ ] things when did it
become a church
uh yeah when did it become a church
Joker Church yeah it's Jordan Peterson
started the Joker you know I saw a
comment here that I think is [ __ ] so
true Lena's The Joker brain that is so
true
we need to do a poll
because if we're the cast of Batman
look I love Lena
but it was one thing no no no no no no
no no no pregnancy test okay yeah first
of all it wasn't it was not just one
thing it was one incredible thing
it was more than one thing she was
laughing the whole time laughing
giggling silly it was silly and you know
what that's like saying 911 was just one
day
so much more than that
we got to do another pull Ian who's the
real Joker brain Tina
sorry Zach I didn't want this guys did
you guys want to uh but you know Lena uh
leaders don't choose to be leaders or
whatever that right right this is true
the best shoes to be Joker are we really
gonna do Zach like
what yes we
I sent uh the period simulator I don't
know if we want to take a little recap
real quick you can't strip me of this
title it's binding bro it's up to the
people you're not living by your own
words just thank them for being honest
so this is the same thing
may I submit a Counterpoint to Zach's
favor
um okay so Lena's shown exemplary
strength in the face of the Hot Chip and
the pregnancy challenge I would say this
is Bain brain because she's the most
powerful Among Us Bain brain yeah
most powerful
if we're gonna do Joker versus Pain
brain versus Joker brain and then
obviously just in the metaphor I'm
Batman right right obviously about that
I think you kind of give me Mad Hatter
vibes
no I'm Batman let's just be totally
honest about that none of you guys even
give off Batman energy
I'm here for the city I'm here for the
[ __ ] people bro I mean you dance
Commissioner Gordon obviously you've
always been that uh
Batman in the shadows
thank you Ela now we need to do a poll
of CFI Batman you guys better hook me up
once in my life I'm Batman I am Batman
you guys know what picture I'm thinking
about yeah if he's in the hospital yeah
do you guys
do you agree that um Dan is Commissioner
Gordon
in my in my video defending you I
jokingly called you the Batman of the
internet I said you are the silent
guardian and that's why you hear so much
[ __ ] just because you get teamed up on
by all these other people like Batman so
that's actually that's funny and it's so
true and I accept it thank you you're
welcome it is very soon
actually I hate to tell you this act but
Lena has absolutely decimated you in the
polls I humbly accept
able ruined me and Zach's friendship and
now the Joker pulls in ruling and Zach's
friendship don't do this I love you
can't take it away from me you just
can't she just did no you cannot just
buy another Joker mask it's a democracy
you said it's a democracy
fake news fake [ __ ] news
Lena talk speech tell the people talk to
your people
um I just want to say thank you guys I
didn't ask for this but I haven't seen
it a lot in the past few days
yeah I think you're right it is what it
is
well the only thing sack has to do is do
something super Joker brain and we do
another poll in a couple weeks we have
one we have a chip we have one left
maybe
but the people have spoken uh so what is
Zach then if not Joker burned sad
[Music]
I'm defeated is there any other
character you want to be so the penguin
I think we need some sort of like Joker
off uh segment yeah oh that is such a
good idea totally down for that you guys
need to fight for the title of Joker
brains
yo
so fun
I would argue Zack's Mr Freeze
that's pretty cool Mr Freeze is Dub I
had some sick one liners Zach has some
good one-liners Mr Freeze was was a good
dude actually he wasn't even really a
bad villain he was a good dude
[Music]
chill out I have to run to the bathroom
all right okay Ian make sure you write
that down because that definitely needs
to happen
but before we move on
um I do want to just confirm that you
guys think I'm Batman
wait we didn't even go over my point
when you come to a conclusion with that
what what more needs to be done yeah
wait what what do you mean Lena please
go ahead please go ahead wait wait I'm
confused what did we miss
Ian no no no no but let them go at it
just the two of them
don't pull anything like did you want to
re you wanted to respond to Lena no so
what it might mean did you have more to
the PowerPoint this doesn't involve you
I'm sorry shut the [ __ ] up
wait what am I missing are we good what
do you mean are we good are we good what
do you mean are we good are we Bros
do I hate you no because you know we had
some beef are we good
oh did we resolve the beef yeah oh I
think you guys got a trust ball oh the
trust fall okay okay sorry I didn't
understand what the hell you were asking
me for Ethan this pole I've got a whoa
it's not looking good yeah first of all
it's 50 50. how's that not looking good
living a democracy that means that no
I'm not complaining Zach
now let it be known first of all I ate
that whole [ __ ] chip
and I got second place I would have
pushed further but Lena absolutely
destroyed it and there was no point of
pushing on you did take a sip at like 51
seconds in do you want me to can I give
you stop okay one little sip yeah
okay okay can I sell you Batman
begin yeah that was that was a lot this
is it where it is you had to sip at the
beginning too
again that probably helped you more I
actually chewed it and swallowed it down
and but you also had to sip with it at
the beginning
I hit the water and then I hit the milk
real fast it actually made it hurt more
cam you can't be serious I'm just
throwing the pot here I like the Joker
brain Energy's in the air right now okay
you guys are so okay let me let me let
me sell Ethan is Batman okay
as I said before it takes on the whole
internet get [ __ ] for it burns Bridges
every episode because he's selfless he
only cares about what's right this man
could have been easily sitting next to
Joe Rogan not many times many times
that's what he chose to speak up for
what's right that sounds very Bruce
Wayne of him he has lost money
I ain't saying [ __ ] that's on his mind
because like Bruce Wayne he doesn't care
about money he cares about Justice
that's true that's true and also like
Bruce Wayne I'm a Playboy handsome stud
that all the ladies want that's not for
sure don't forget that
[Music]
that's true is this pole binding Ethan
uh yeah but I I agree to it being
binding but I just don't know why you
guys have to be such dicks like look at
this like everybody gets to be whoever
the [ __ ] they want I don't I lost well
to Lena but it doesn't matter when it
was penguin versus Joker they wrote for
you but my own people my own people
they saying 52 no
when I'm clearly and Batman I think
you're the Godfather
um Corleone you come to me
I put up a pole for my own fans
you come to me and you vote no no
after all I've done for you
four days a week
no three and a half hours
and here you disrespect me on my own
pull no
why are you flashing
[Music]
you disrespect me in my own pull
I'm Bruce Wayne
I'm Batman
how dare you
and all of my family which I love
they get to be who they want
ban is Hopper ah Emma
I
could divert your eyes please to the
screen uh-huh
that is the [ __ ] Caped Crusader
perched on the city top
after all I've done fan
[Music]
unbelievable and then either that makes
you Catwoman I guess
you could be Catwoman
[Music]
whatever the people think Zach is having
his Jason Todd into Redwood Arc right
now I have no idea what that means
what the [ __ ]
I'm not even gonna read this one this
guy said Dan has the tech and skills
with them to be Batman it's not all
about tech and skill dude we gotta
understand that the fact that Batman's
good on lap on
desktop doesn't mean anything but who
gets it Batman all of his gear and like
the
he's like Alfred you see me throw that
ball remember how I it's really good
with them be Alfred yeah Dan would be
Alfred or Commissioner Gordon I think
he's more Alfred actually
because Alfred knows all the the gadgets
and [ __ ] yo where'd the poll go
the Pole's still open why'd you close it
Ian
[Music]
you serious
no no that was you got to do me so dirty
making a comeback and you closed the
[ __ ] pole I'm gonna throw up another
one Zach's The Riddler for sure
I'll take that
but you want to be the ruler I just said
Zach's or I mean Ian's The Riddler sorry
I meant what the [ __ ] dude Ian's The
Riddler for closing the pole oh Harley
Quinn kind of like the Joker
doesn't make sense all right we gotta
please throw up the Batman again this is
important I want to move on but
people are saying I'm Lego Batman stop
it
what does that even mean
[Laughter]
Lego Batman is still bad
guys just remember the good times thank
you thank you for the record I'm voting
yes too even thank you chairman
just remember all I do for you guys four
times a week three and a half hours I
put my spotty My Soul on the line for
you guys let the record show I voted yes
as well thank you thank you finally
all the trolls are out of here all the
tater tots are voting no
bad pull s is this is a great poll it's
simply written hard to misunderstand
we're getting hard yeses people thank
you thank you peace and love peace and
love this is a serious message I want to
tell you thank you thank you after
September 16th I will be known as Batman
please peace and love peace and love any
mentions
of Ethan thank you well be tossed in the
bin from now on it's Batman or Bruce
Wayne thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love
thank you we can lock that pull up now
yeah
thank you guys it's meaningful
what do you mean on Lego Batman
that's [ __ ] up I love that
yeah it's kind of badass
all right there you have it you can call
me Batman from now on guys just Mr
Batman
Mr Bat you call me the bat it's fine
love Mark
you know less formal
you could call me bat
that'd be fine
all right so Zach we need to resolve our
beef
I I'm squashed I think you did a
beautiful PowerPoint Zach and
um
actually I was gonna say that you are
Joker brain until Lina came through and
she posed you
hey
we ended one beef but started another
yeah that's how it is that's right have
it don't care we live in a society and
that's the rule well hold on we're gonna
do a great Joker off and that's really
gonna decide but Zach come up here so we
can do a trust ball
but my my beef is squashed uh is your
beef squashed yeah I'm cool homie we
good are you not coming up here no I
just changed the music
we have to do a trust fall you'll do oh
squash the beef really I think that's
the official HR got it thanks and uh
okay
now that Zach's a pretty big heavy guy
so is he who he's falling on you or are
you on him or both ways
we know we do it both ways
okay
yeah either can you just scoot a little
bit out you want to do me first
what's going on
ready yeah
oh [ __ ] I really fell for you bro
how much you weigh
yeah
come on I got you I'm in my Powers no
I'm in my power stance I will not drop
you sure you okay you weigh more than
230.
can we get you on a scale you want to
Wavy
[Laughter]
oh my God the show minimum oh my God
not that you're back listen you're super
tall I weigh like 250 bro I still way
more than you I lost 10 pounds I still
weigh two and you're looking spelled and
I'm very proud of you I'm not calling
you big or fat you're just a massive
dude I'm a big dude yeah I've gained
weight I'll admit that
it's not what I meant
Kobe you're looking better better than
ever though I gotta say
it is
you talking about me or him yeah Zach
you well thank you well of course why
are we complimenting that I'm the one
please keep the focus on me all right up
next uh Ela versus Zach did you know
about this Zach
uh maybe so ELO filed a complaint with
me
PowerPoint though
it's a minor minor one Ela filed a
complaint about uh Zach saying that she
hates when Zach plays the sound bite of
ela saying I want to smell feet Yes she
says it no she says first of all she
never remembers that it happened
and she always asks Zach to please stop
playing that sound bite here it is for
your recollection matters yeah oh yeah
you should I farted on the feet I farted
on feet it should say dude that's a good
I want to smell feet so this is you did
say it here but I am not speaking for
myself
I'm not saying I want to smell feet
right you were talking about I don't
even remember what are we talking about
here you feed I would assume the words
were did come out of your mouth
you do want to smell feet so play the
sound bite for Zach I want to smell it
sometimes he'll drop that and and you
know what bothers you about this sound
bar that I really don't like feet
actually so fit you don't like feet at
all no so it's not even your your
problem is that it's not even true it's
far oh speaking
Seaman wait
yeah he's rescheduled is it us or him uh
it's him he said he just needs uh some
more time so Siemens needs he he needs
another hour everybody's rescheduling
okay sorry to interrupt I just just uh
get what so you don't like feet that's
your problem there uh-huh
I think that it's um when you cut out
the context
it's using my voice
and
I just feel like there's a HR moment
there yeah he's it's almost like he's
making a sexual he's making it sexual
about you I didn't say sexual oh it's
almost like Zack's arrest you know it's
almost like so canceled whoa
almost like Zach isn't the Joker and he
also is canceled that's all I've got to
say about today I guess
just kidding Zach
look Elena if it makes you uncomfortable
I can stop playing it
okay
oh that was easy do you want to say
anything other than that no I I look you
know I I try and do my job and you know
if certain someone doesn't like
something then I'll stop Loki Joker move
that was a good move
I agree with that now there there is
another one
um
about the the black
is that one okay
have you visited blocked no that was
a question that I asked Belle Delphine
when she was on the show so I don't have
a problem with that one okay because
that was a question that I thought about
and I chose to put it out there which is
fine that makes sense to me okay yeah it
was a truly posed question it's a porn
in feed out
yeah Locked In Black then fade out
I got it have you been to block the dog
have you visited
no no
they're fans of the show up there
didn't they want to sponsor us yeah they
did that's funny we probably sent a lot
of traffic guard those black people
should know us also team skeet owes
those big points yeah
you're really leaning into the den
is outside the current it's stressful a
lot of stuff pre-show and during the
show at least you want to eat okay well
that do you guys want to do a trust fall
or you guys could probably I don't know
if you want to do that or not I think
we're cool yeah I think we're cool yeah
okay cool I sent you a message on
Discord there attack just so make sure
you don't miss that it's important
yeah so anyway moving on
[Laughter]
Nick Cannon welcomes his ninth child
Nick Cannon
AKA Genghis Khan that now can I say
something yeah that dude [ __ ] literally
you need to stop [ __ ] this man needs
to put it away I don't understand this
is everyone agrees that this is like not
a good thing right I mean being the dad
of in nine different families I mean
you're these kids are gonna have they're
gonna be fatherless
it's impossible for him is it like a
fetish I mean what is happening there's
no way that he can attend all those kids
and be an actual good dad to all of them
it's just physically impossible but also
the fact that they're all different moms
yeah like even the more even the Mormons
back in the day didn't [ __ ] like with
this much but they had like nine wives
all different kids maybe they did in
2021 he had four children with three
different women
crazy numbers and then isn't it
happening again now this year so here's
the details I have Nick Cannon just
welcomed his ninth child yeah there's
two on the way two other separate women
who are pregnant
and then there was a I heard maybe you
could confirm this that there was a
surprise baby that just happened like
today or yesterday that like he just had
his tent that nobody knew about he
welcomed a son named legendary in June
legendary uh then she announced that she
was pregnant again but did not reveal
who the father was fans has speculated
that it's Canon he hasn't commented yet
about that pregnancy
um in July Canon said he could have
three kids by 2020 in 2022.
but for right now in the dock we have a
breakdown of who's who yeah who he has
kids with so just to say yeah he has two
more on the way from two different women
Mariah Carey has two of his kids it's
interesting
Brittany Bell is that someone I don't
know two kids one on the way
so these women are okay with him [ __ ]
everybody I'm assuming
is that interesting too
this man has a schedule do you
understand
like when he gets off work he goes from
house to house impregnating women
because it you know we've been through
it fertility is not always easy when
you're trying to get nine different
women pregnant
some are going to hit some are going to
miss some take more effort than others
this man is trick-or-treating
from house to house but he's he's just
[ __ ] impregnating women
it's not okay I don't know what to say I
added with it some kind of weird thing
yeah I'd like to know like what is his
what's going on in his brain because
there's clearly he's doing something you
know either it's a religious thing yeah
it's a fetish thing well like like musk
is kind of doing the same thing now
that's true he thinks that he's on
submission to populate Earth they had a
Twitter exchange about it making a joke
about it together oh [ __ ] and Elon wait
pull that up
yo we have a Nick catry fan we have a
Nick Cannon family tree oh my God
he's having a big joke out of it this is
going to be one hell of a tree in like
20 years
that dude Fox
yeah we got to do something about it
it's not a good way to raise kids you
know in my humble opinion kids need
their daddies
this is like this old school mentality
of like and I think
he's really doing this where it's like
oh the mother's raised the kids
everybody knows how important the mother
is to their kids who is my daddy
throughout history people don't
appreciate that kids also need dads
equally as important
and I think this is that old school
thing oh the mother takes care of them
I'll show up on their birthday I guess
I'll take them for an ice cream on
Sunday
I feel like
uh people our age are definitely
involved in their kids life like the dad
and the mom big changed big time because
people are having first of all smaller
families we're having double parent
households where both the parents are
working so it's more of a communal thing
but that's also just like an
understanding that yeah 100 it's it
takes both of them being there I'll be
honest I think a lot of
the reason why older Generations are
[ __ ] up is because they these people
were raised without dads I really do
think that because back in the 50s there
was a single parent household the moms
took care of the kids the dad would come
home and then the whole attitude was
like I don't I'm tired I don't want to
[ __ ] deal with the kids it's not my
job it's your job
and these people effectively grew up
without a dad I mean I kind of I mean I
you know whatever my dad me and my dad
are close we're happy now but like
effectively I didn't really grow up with
the close relationship with my dad
I guess
um
a little a little correction in the chat
but these days we should not only think
about that and Mom it's just two parents
because
which is true sure yeah right two
parents whatever studies show that
same-sex marriages uh raise kids just as
happy and well adjusted thank you
Loki homophobic shut up
somebody wrote that I'm talking I'm not
talking about that okay so it's like yes
two same-sex marriages are fine bro how
many [ __ ] times I gotta say that
how am I being homophobic
oh my god dude
yo it's like crazy how y'all twist
yourselves up sometimes to get offended
like you clearly know what I'm talking
about
stop
do you guys want me to be authentic and
speak my mind or not
sometimes it just comes from
not being not fully thinking about
everything else that's out there and not
like this is maybe the first time we're
talking about something like that so we
don't we're not aware of what we're
excluding by talking just about our
situation look people need to use their
[ __ ] brain they know what I mean but
if you like I'm not gonna we can't just
pretend like they don't know what the
[ __ ] I mean right I mean they gotta
remember being homophobic you you fight
for equal rights almost every show you
say something you make a comment
every [ __ ] show I talk about
um I mean of course single you know it's
a it's just I just think like things are
like changing there's always progress
and it just takes like you just give
somebody an opportunity to correct and
we literally just did that it's just
but I think everybody needs to
understand it's like everybody's like
changing and growing and like sometimes
you just unaware that if you say
something a certain way it might come
off as like excluding other people it
takes somebody to tell you then you
learn that I don't think it's like I
understand what you're saying but I do
think that people sometimes need to stop
like
putting too much on what people say like
you know what the [ __ ] I meant when I'm
talking about
kids need dads I'm not talking about
same-sex relationships we can talk about
that but like you can't just [ __ ] get
offended you know what I meant like why
do I gotta explain everything and every
little nuance
all right let's let's do a pride minute
I was gonna say you're the founder of
Pride minute I mean come on now it's
just ridiculous all right come on Prime
minute
foreign
you guys can raise a kid together two
gays two women
studies show
and I don't even need a study to know
this that same
sex marriages are very healthy very
equally healthy equally enriching for
kids
you know
what really matters is love right and
the influence of two different parents
because one parent is one type of way
and another parent's another type of way
exactly you need that you need two
people that are your parents that love
you and support you and understand you
and that's
what lgbtq plus Pride minute means
okay
so shout out to all my same-sex
marriages out there
let's get those kids coming let's get
those kids let's get these gays some
kids God damn it what can we do to speed
it up we need gays to have more kids and
I mean that
you know ask Nick Cannon if yes you got
any kids laying around
yeah
so you got a timer going maybe
somebody's supposed to time oh I didn't
know it's over stop
all right
no more all right listen back in the
[ __ ] closet I'm sick of pandering to
all the gays I have to over explain
myself you know what gays
you are abomination in the eyes of
Christ
how dare you want a child to raise with
your partner disgusting
the Bible clearly says
that two men shall not raise a child
that two women shall never raise a child
be gone case
to damn Nation
now just the other day
I stubbed my goddamn toe
on the couch and I said damn the gays
if it weren't for another man kiss
another man I would never goddamn hit my
toe
amen
we'll get cancer in the Bible say God
damn them gays no this is going to be a
minute right
no
homophobic minute lasts as long as God
deems you change
[Music]
goodness for the righteous man
that one time I'll tell you what man
when I was a young young lad I kissed a
brother I kissed another dude oh you did
and my heart fluttered with a thousand
butterflies that sounds good but I
realized Lord
that I was committing to the Grave is
sin sounds like you were having a happy
moment I I don't know how Dan does this
so it just has to keep going this is our
life now I felt worthless damn you and
my I went to the church and I heard my
good preacher say two [ __ ] I've never
embraced I felt ugly Hurricane Katrina
will never hit land for them gays I felt
gay
that Hurricane Katrina
I felt that no that like that's based on
what they told me
but never hit no goddamn Florida okay
if I never kissed that boy at 12th grade
and I said
I'm not gay no more
I am gay and I'm back in the closet and
so shall y'all be tuned now go to hell
you demon-ass game
oh I think I think Dan's taking the
computer again uh-oh Dan what you doing
the ghost of Dan
what's he doing
[Music]
I must said doing my best to help the
underpopulation crisis I love that he
invented this crisis just so he could
like have a billion kids
Elon Musk has been saying that
underpopulation is going to be the
biggest threat facing Humanity
I'll be honest
I don't know about that I agree with him
populations are declining and it's going
to cause huge problems in society
because people are having less kids in
fact populations
are starting to go down in a lot of
Western countries a lot of European
countries Japan okay that being said I
think there's a lot of smart people that
know about this so it's not that [ __ ]
interesting
but
is the solution to just have a bunch of
musk babies that hate their own dad it's
it's actually so insane it's like yeah
you guys can afford to have a hundred
kids that's the [ __ ] problem you're
both like disgustingly wealthy so you
can have a [ __ ] billion kids the
reason the real reason that people
aren't having kids in Western countries
because it's too [ __ ] expensive
that's the real reason so good for you
dude it's like turning into a status
symbol like Elon Musk just wants his
little [ __ ] uh
all each one kid there's like a feather
in his cap like check me out
am I right am I wrong
you're always right am I right or wrong
oh adorbs
I'm waiting to hear you say that for
years am I right or wrong am I right or
wrong
so um
yeah Elon said doing my best to help the
underpopulation crisis is a collapsing
birth rate is the biggest danger to
society Nick Cannon says right there
with you my brother okay whatever yeah
right freaks we live in a society if you
really cared about under if you thought
it was such an existential crisis you'd
be like yo we need Universal
preschool right we need preschool we
need benefits for for
um poor families to supplement their
income and feed their children if it was
that big of a threat why are you not
doing that because the world is not
going to [ __ ] care that you had 10
extra kids the only people are going to
Care is your damn kids they don't have a
dad
and he does have a kid that disowned him
or something right oh yeah
yeah he has he has a trans daughter or
something that disowned him yeah they're
how's that working out for you Elan yeah
she dropped his last name yo his own
flesh and blood has disowned him Vivian
Jenna Wilson
father of the year
she said she wishes to not be related to
him in any way shape or form we support
you I love how he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about that he's like yes or what yes
he's got a lawnmower it's just
statistics that one of them
maybe that's why he started numbering
his kids yeah he thinks it's oh for real
yeah it's like a math equation so maybe
one will not make it or yeah it's like
fine One's Gonna Be a [ __ ] up yeah I get
it he's like pop on Stranger Things yep
11 and
XI
somebody says they think you like me
um
stop it guys you're in bro I don't want
to be
I know it's a workspace
but
is there feeling something here or
something
you want you to do something tonight
maybe I'll pick it up later like what
are you experiencing what are you
feeling right now Ela has to crush on
anything people say it feelings
you know I'm just trying to play it cool
feelings I don't know I don't I are you
technically my boss here at the podcast
oh no you own that you own 50 of this
company I'm not your boss okay
because I was gonna say this could be an
HR complication
well I'm not your boss baby and I never
was so talk to me
um yeah so Nick Cannon had nine kids uh
this man yeah I mean that's it what more
can you say
total of nine kids two more on the way
we got 11 kids and I've Loved kids we
gotta limit the number don't you think
oh that would be nice I think he has his
Jizz In Like a squirt bottle he just
walks around squirting women like like
you do with a plant you know to keep it
healthy
come
the man is a [ __ ] come demon dude
coming
uh okay so there you go see man's we
have about 30 minutes until c-man
himself calls in oh so you're fine yeah
he just postponed a little bit ELO what
do you want for dinner tonight that's a
good question
lately I want like something really good
and I have no idea what that means I
have a really small breakfast so I can
go wild for dinner and I haven't touched
anything I had yogurt hard-boiled egg
and a fruit and a big old fiber drink so
I'm I've had about like 250 calories
which means I can go buck [ __ ]
wild for dinner
do you want to address this
overpopulation problem or not me and you
tonight
just saying can't let these kids we
can't let these two guys repopulate the
world
Lena and a b come on get moving 90 times
soon we can bring the kids to work
yeah I mean well
I could see us having like a daycare or
something for the kids but Cam's gonna
be watching when the kids in the
background or something don't worry I
don't want to watch kids come on Ian Sam
come on we need to repopulate it's an
existential crisis
absolutely no time soon oh [ __ ] so so
it's up to Elon Musk and Nick Cannon I
guess
yeah Lena's parents ask us all the time
and we're like so what are we gonna do
when we go to work where are we gonna We
have no family here you know it's not
even about work we just have no family
we have no help yeah that's hard yeah my
mom says I can send the baby to Michigan
and she'll take care of it oh my God I
know
it sounds horrible and she has like 12
grandkids already I'm like I think
you're fine there's no loneliness in
that house she already watches like all
the grandkids you guys will have such a
beautiful baby though coming thank you
thank you I'm afraid it's gonna look
like those Reddit memes
[Laughter]
hmm no Lena would never let that happen
Lena's jeans yeah my last name that's it
no your jeans as well the first thing
Lena and I said after that episode was
that photo does not look like you oh
just so you know oh thank you I hope
that was it's just a final minute it's
just yeah it's just funny
it's funny it's hilarious I'm dying I
wanted to talk about
um there's this YouTuber dream you guys
probably are if you haven't heard of
them super super super popular
that's him he's a Minecraft
hell yeah YouTuber
the only reason I know about him is
because he had this incredible cheating
scandal
wait he put out a world record like he
beat Minecraft in like a world record
time oh and so mathematician came out
and was like what happened is
statistically impossible it's like one
in a trillion oh my gosh and then and
then dream hired some quacks to
statistician to put out like uh rebuttal
rebuttal and it was like totally [ __ ]
fake Lord oh my God
and he was forced to admit that
actually was funny he didn't really
admit he tried he's like oh yeah I did
maybe had this program open and didn't
realize really yeah and he's a huge in
the Minecraft community and like he
obviously cheated and lied about it and
like embarrassingly hired a scientist a
statistician to write a paper
and it was he has 30 million Subs he has
nuts
um
so and then is he the one with the voice
the crazy yeah he doesn't show his face
yeah are you think a corpse baby oh I'm
thinking yeah okay no right neither of
them show their face that's like the new
Vibe yeah smart I guess these these
dudes making Shadows no no but
look at the views yeah he's got monster
views
um you know they all have like
19 14 43 it's insane yeah it's nuts
let's go what what's fascinating to me
is like the title and the thumbnail are
traditionally you would think like not
good at all right like that yeah
Minecraft speedrun versus a million I
mean it's just it looks like a bunch of
[ __ ] Minecraft speed run versus 5 Hunter
Grand Finale 43 million and the
thumbnail is just like some random frame
under 80 million
that's wild holy [ __ ] wow 72 million
what the hell and it just says Minecraft
speedrunner versus five Hunters rematch
I didn't even know what that means oh my
God 72 million
yeah so it's a he's a big deal
but I just this whole cheating scandal
was super embarrassing and
I don't know but nobody cared ultimately
at least his fans didn't but he's in a
new kind of controversy here and I'm
curious what's your take on the Selah
because I don't think you know about it
he just dropped new merch
it's a bracelet
that comes with a USB drive here
September members only slap bracelet
flash drive with special dream content
two-week pre-sale
so it's 25 bucks you have to be a member
to buy it by the way so dream never
showed themselves he's never showed his
face no at least the modern no I don't
think he's ever showed his face some
people were trying to to leak his face
um but yeah he never oh yeah he can
never show his face is that you it's you
sorry one sec I don't even know where my
phone is it's uh Tick Tock it's
recording oh [ __ ]
uh
I can hear a little I can hear you
you heard me though yeah um
yeah that's fine
um
Ted [ __ ] Cruz uh Happy Birthday dream
my daughters asked me to say that
yeah you see Hassan's response below
that you fell off hopefully plus
premature L for Texas plus ratio from an
elephant permanent Alpha protected yeah
that's that's pretty badass
uh Ted Cruz such a piece of [ __ ] this is
a this is like a curse on your house
yeah you know when Ted Cruz wishes you a
happy birthday man
so I kind of want to wait for ELO to
explain it
yeah because I want her to know but I'm
gonna show more pictures so you guys can
see
oh yeah here this is a great photo
it's got like his heartbeat on it
and a zip Drive
off the charts but always and your heart
I'll wait till you hear what's on that
Zip drive
but wait there's more
all right Ela here I gotta
ela's coming back here
yes so it's a bracelet
it has his heartbeat on it and a USB
Drive okay
yeah it's this thing here it's 25 bucks
here's what's on the Zip drive
flash drive contains special dream
content contents include baby pictures
[Music]
some chapters from dreams old books
childhood emails
old Gaming screenshots
pictures memes from dreams camera roll
and more
combining the fun of a slap bracelet
with the utility of a USB
what the [ __ ] I I just so weird what's
weird to me about this particular is
because dream never shows his face but
he has this insane para social
relationship with his fans were they
like fantasize that he's like some
Dreamboat dream cutie there's all this
fan art of him like being this like honk
and I think there's a lot of people that
you know it'll be kind of badass if I
never showed my face people think I was
attractive and that helps you know you
could be whatever they want I probably
have so many more fans if I didn't show
my face [ __ ] everyone be like damn
Ethan's so fine it's a total Batman move
dude
dream is Batman
but it seems super exploitative and
weird and just creepy and weird
like the man he doesn't show his face so
he cares about his privacy yet
he's selling his fans his most emails
what does that mean his childhood email
it's like it's like I don't know but
like
he it's like the way he's like inviting
them into his personal world like yeah I
will sell you this glimpse into my most
personal world yeah
because you don't know anything about me
into my face sending baby pictures I
mean this is just so odd to me
I don't know so did you guys order one
well no but that's actually a great idea
yeah
we have to become a member Dan actually
just sent a message he wanted to relay
he said major Boomer alert calling it a
zip drive over and over what the [ __ ]
dude what should I call it
Boomer flash drive or flash drive Boomer
okay whatever damn it you're not even
here I talk [ __ ] from the car
you know besides the baby pictures
what's really weird is that it's a uh a
slap bracelet what's it called that's
for kids that's for like eight-year-olds
yeah
hell no isn't it kids who watch him yes
that's true it's kids it's little
girlies but just a USB and a slap
bracelet so weird to me because you're
like hitting the the drive each time you
put it on those new ones are crazy
durable like I don't know that
Ethan would be Batman but Batman
actually shows up on time that's a good
point
that is a good point
well I don't Batman shows up when he's
needed okay not you know
um also the membership so you have to be
a member to buy this thing
and what are you a member of 15 25 and
15 bucks he has an email SMS
you get an email from him
a member's discount on merch I love that
you go if you pay me monthly you can
have a discount to pay me more money
yeah what this is crazy
one free item per order again of up to
eight dollars
what are you selling for eight bucks
what
what again it's like yo I'ma hook you up
when you buy me something
exclusive at one members
such a salesperson this guy
dude like he's and these there's got to
be so many people on this
he says one or more member only products
members only item will be pre-ordered I
don't know what that means
gold you get yo if you you get 15 off
and up to ten dollars of a free item
now I'm talking Platinum let's see what
comes here up to twelve dollar you get a
12 free item a month when you pay 50
bucks
a month
such a privilege to be able to buy his
merch
Early Access to drops dude I'm it's all
just about buying [ __ ] from him yeah you
paid money to buy more [ __ ] but you pay
money to get an emails man it's the best
this is the best membership ever it's
not like an extra video yeah you know
it's like no buy [ __ ] more [ __ ]
you get one day early access to drops
you get priority processing means you
get it sooner when you buy [ __ ]
and then you also get a creating a
greeting card okay that's that's
something but you have to be a premium
member for the greeting card and that's
a month a month
I don't know how these kids thought
their parents into that 50 how do you
convince your parents to buy a 50
subscription
50
damn this dude knows what he's doing
though huh
let's see what he's selling yeah so the
bracelets the new one oh it's a pre-sale
smart then you have to install he
doesn't have to invest in any
uh
Members Only
Dream Smile cuffed beanie
holy [ __ ]
you guys
the dream Club
25 bucks
let's go
yo this guy has got this set the [ __ ] up
you have to be a member to buy this
got my brain turning I'm about to milk
you guys dry watching about to make
members out of y'all
waste that sweet milk
what's this October smile Club ornament
[ __ ] selling Christmas ornaments
that look like this
coming soon October Members Only
oh my god oh you're gonna they're gonna
vote for which one they wanna buy
crazy you gotta be a member to buy the
merch
[Music]
dude that's wild I would love to know
what he's making yeah which one would
you guys vote for to buy
number three yeah number three because
No One's Gonna know what the other three
are this is literally just a generic
basic like water green flakes all right
this one just looks bad
this one I don't know what the [ __ ] yeah
I mean this is the only one there yeah
yeah that's that one's gonna win for
sure
oh my God it's not even an ornament it's
just like it's a flat thing
a disc just to clarify it's annual not
monthly
okay oh okay that that actually
that actually makes it a lot that's like
50 a month
that makes it a lot more uh uh sense
are you sure you did it you double
checked that 50 let me look again 50
annual members you're right you're right
you're right
okay shout out dream uh very generous
very generous of dream
let's check out some of those other
products find this interesting
okay
dream uh okay this stuff's fine
no problem here
[Music]
okay shout out dream
love that so curious what this person
looks like
well they did a there's like yeah
there's always been a lot of drama about
people trying to dox him and stuff but
[Music]
I don't think we ever have seen his face
is there anything under eight dollars
for the free item on there that's what
I'm wondering I mean here's a sticker
pack
you know one free item
this is five bucks so you could get the
sticker pack for free
we give free stickers with all orders at
Teddy fresh right let's go and the tag
itself is a sticker yeah that tag itself
costs more money than that sticker pack
yeah this one's just see this one's 13
bucks so you couldn't get this one
that's a three pack I just wonder like
is this like a young or an old person oh
he's probably young he's the mid-20s
yeah I think you can tell by the voice
he's yeah and also he said he's younger
I believe at one point he's got to be 25
Max 23. yeah that makes sense to me a
lot of these super popular YouTubers are
really young about that age you know
cool man
very cool
it's just great guys head over to
dream.shop get your
get your USB drive yeah I'm actually
planning on making my own wonders only
Merchant myself you drive with a
close-up of my butthole
only members can see it
I'm going fully prolapsed for you guys
oh
gross yeah
what do we do about it well I'm just
wondering how can I be more personal
with our fans I already everything I
have to do is on display other than
showing my butthole the number one
podcast in the world
if you guys pay us I'll show you like
pictures of Teddy's face so that don't
care about my son's privacy
here all of you for 30 bucks oh here's a
video of me pushing Teddy on the swing
that's perverted that's kind of what
he's doing
there it is interesting
so it might say fascinating
um
others might yet say move on
and that's what I'll be doing
um Drake first fantano this was a great
story man A lot of people are requesting
this and yeah so actually I gotta pee
and then we'll do it I'll be right back
[Music]
let's see anything in the chat
God
so
someone asked ELO would you sell the
teddy fresh stickers for our Christmas
tree
all right Christmas tree
we're there Chris
I'm not sure I understand that like make
them into ornaments Maybe
if I would just sell the stickers Maybe
um I don't
no I feel like if we were to sell
stickers then I would try to make them
like
bigger or
or like a sheet of stickers which is out
of doing
that'd be cool yeah
you know we're working on right now is a
little
eraser like a teddy bear eraser like the
logo oh that's cute yeah and that would
be a freebie with the orders when it's
ready oh that's so good I love to get a
fancier Racers and fancy pencils before
I pay a membership to buy that
for sure yearly
but that is still in development right
now
the eraser
Carly says Eli I've been mainly
listening to this app and not watching
but I just tuned in and that sweater is
so fire I need it oh thank you
you know some designs that we do are
like stuff that I personally sketch and
then some designs are like it's a
collaborative effort where like we we
all pull inspiration together and talk
about it and then the some designers
will sketch ideas and then we'll go over
it together
so there's all kinds of different
ways that we go about it this one is one
that I personally sketched oh nice
thank you the design and the colors are
awesome especially I feel like at this
time of year people are gonna love that
yeah you said next week yeah
and there's a pastel one tell me more
what color oh no no okay yeah yeah
I'm excited about it though someone said
Ethan and Eva should be Bob and Joyce
I like that idea
I don't know if Ethan will like plain
Bob yeah yeah no I think he would love
it he loves Bob yeah yeah well I hear
him
someone said put scuffed a B on a
sticker
let's not
another idea for them May
come like that would be fun my fashion
Susie would be sober like a nightgown
and the glasses and you guys were long
distance at first too yeah oh my God
that's so true what would they talk
through walkie-talkies yeah we used to
describe
you guys could sing The Neverending
Story theme like like they do you're
good
Ethan's gonna hate that
I think a little like it better than Bob
though
what am I gonna hate someone suggested
that you guys go as Joyce and Bob for uh
Halloween
Joyce and Bob Bob Newby he was the
character you loved so much Sean Austin
uh Sam wise Genji how do you even like
him
that's what I said and you said that's
not the point yeah but it's easier for
you to drive that good
but I already I already look like him
I literally have the same I got the body
[ __ ] Rudy dude I think it's a cute
idea and then there's also
um Susie and Dustin yeah Susie and
Dustin could be really cute
Susie and Dustin is that of stranger
things yeah yeah his girlfriend
girlfriend the genius yeah oh right
didn't they break up or something in the
new one no he moved away no she saves
the day they have a fart yeah they go to
her to save the day yeah twice oh yeah
she's the hacker yeah and she has a
bunch of siblings when you go to her
house
hey that could be cute
I like that one that one yeah me too
yeah
hey um
um guys is there a new Game of Thrones
tonight is that that's a Friday thing
Sunday I thought right or am I wrong
[ __ ] okay there's something on Friday
right what is it Lord of the Rings Lord
of the Rings oh [ __ ] it's Lord of the
Rings day
okay
you know I've been watching one piece
though people have been asking for One
Piece updates yeah I'm on episode like
355. I'm so bummed that I didn't join
Ethan on that one from the beginning and
now I just feel like it will forever be
too late for me to join so 350 episodes
yeah I'm not even gonna attempt but I
still have like 700 left and yeah yeah I
can't no it's never gonna end too it's
gonna keep going on forever now you know
that show's been on the air for 21 years
since 1999
19.99 wait cam do you watch all of it I
started it but like there's it's just
too much I like closure do people think
it's still good though or is it like no
people love it I see it like on the
front page of Reddit from the manga like
uh that's impressive people are it's
more popular than ever I think
but I think the the story is always
progressing like what I like about it
is I'm in 350 episodes and usually like
Hunter Hunter my favorite anime is like
done by then and so much has happened
but in one piece things are always
happening like they're getting a new
there's always new people joining the
crew and stuff and um
the dynamic of the characters and stuff
is always changing so the story is
ongoing you know did you tell them how
Theodore calls it peace one yeah
yeah and we we kept correcting him and
we're like one piece and he would repeat
it please one I said no one piece I see
people I see people saying that it's
actually coming they're on the last Saga
now
ah yeah right
that's what I say the guy said it's
going to end in two years within two
years I'm seeing online the manga will
end between 2024 and 2025 so yeah but it
it makes sense because like the store as
long as it is and it sounds ridiculous
to people who don't watch it
the story is it knows where it's going
it's like insane to say that but like
they setting up stuff that's sewing in
the first season 20 years 21 years they
setting stuff up in the first season
that they're that like is only now
starting to pay off in like episode 350.
crazy I mean it's totally nuts but it's
good it's also really interesting to
watch the animation involved because
obviously 1999 animation when it started
it was just a square box yeah
yeah it's really cool to watch the show
evolve
oh the animation evolved I'm sorry I'm
saying it's officially confirmed that
they're on the last Saga last Saga dude
okay oh that's gonna be so that's why
everyone's losing their mind on Reddit
21. yeah
and then it's gonna have 10 spin-off
series
well that's fine I'm just waiting for
them to break up the last Attack on
Titan season four more times
final season part one part two
they're dragging it
but I'm I'm loving it people are asking
what Arc I'm on I'm on the um
the uh what's his name Moria Arc
it's awesome they're saying I should
watch it I I want to but I feel like I
will never catch up so now I'm like
stuck in this like
Shoulda Woulda Coulda
uh I mean I I says I think there's a
chance that you can start watching with
me and I can explain some background but
the thing is I can't miss 300 episodes
yeah it's a lot of Lord to miss people
are saying uh talk about Trisha it's not
happening guys you know
about congratulations no I'm happy the
baby's healthy I mean you know of course
oh yeah Thriller bark yeah you guys know
damn there's some real [ __ ] one-piece
heads in chat yeah I'm watching the
Thriller bark Saga
and I'll tell you guys the one before
um
the water the water seven Arc where they
go attack uh any any Lobby was so
[ __ ] sick
when um Frankie joins the crew and they
get the new ship it's so [ __ ] sick
sick sick sick
yeah this is sick
um I'm just wasting time until Seaman
gets here before I thought you wanted to
talk about the uh I started watching One
it's really cute oh ranking of Kings
yeah I love that yeah see I'm watching
with Ila but Mike the pace is too slow
it's I don't know what time anymore it's
not fair you know we used to binge watch
shows like
stay up all night like I can't do that
kind of stuff
um
yes so I barely have like one hour to
watch something every day you know Dan's
in the chat he said drama hounds coping
and seething
yeah congrats I mean my official
statement is congratulations you know
Dan says get a life loser thank you dude
go off Danny you're not on the clock so
please give me his own account we're
happy for them and I'm just glad the
babies helped the issues it's cute she
looks very beautiful and um
peace and love that's you know what I
mean
what can I say
obviously
what did you think I was gonna say yeah
damn that healthy baby
okay so while we wait for c-man I'll do
the chair Arc
okay yes so what's that there's a link
in the dock of her content
all right so Dad friend of the show uh
who boxed beside a B in the Creator
Clash yep he was on the show everybody
enjoyed him he absolutely demolished
Matt Watson yeah literally murdered him
how long that fight lasts like 10
seconds yeah a minute 30 I think
so he
I saw that Mega awesome sent me this
little chair
um where's that little thing Superman
super mega
the dude whatever his name is McGee Tits
McGee
and um
so Dad got jealous uh that there's a
little spooked they sent me this blinged
out
Bedazzled crocked tiny chair for my fat
ass they put three together I think it's
I think it's still and so Dad saw this
and he says well I'm not going to be
warned up
by these
thank you Tits McGee fellas these uh
super awesome what's their name
super mega
better super mega awesome nerd I think
yeah yeah yeah
so here's the whole spooked mode so Dad
thought he was going to be coming on top
and roasting them but I have to say Dad
is about to get roasted hard because
look what the [ __ ] happened uh you
weren't communicating with him right
here let me pull up this photo hold on
this is outrageous what happened here
um
did his sent here can you what where is
it on here that's in the top of the show
it's number eight thank you
so here we've got for context yeah uh
super awesome show
they gave us on this tiny chair and they
sent me this chair so look at this [ __ ]
what it first of all you were talking to
Dad right Ian
yeah right so so he said tell me what
happens uh nothing he wanted to uh he
felt like you were disrespected by uh
the super mega dudes and he wanted to
show you the respect you deserve and he
said he wanted to send you a king's
chair as you deserve and uh I guess
you're not happy with it I'm not
familiar with what's how did it arrive
hi in four separate boxes
um here go yeah yeah
what why are you guys being quiet who
was I talking to about this you were
talking to Ian about it well
he dad was talking to AV about it and my
understanding is that he said that he
was out of town correct yes and then he
said that he asked if we could put it
together for him yeah he wanted he asked
him Amy why don't you tell the story
it's your story why are you making any
into it because I wasn't sure the angle
right now because I thought we were
actually he wanted us to put together
the chair and uh present it to you and
you deserved this king's chair
and uh yeah he's gonna send a video
about it on Monday
work you guys put in problem is is that
he sent us a chair that we need to
assemble yeah okay so he sent us a chair
and feet but then here's the seat okay
thank you way out befitting a king gay
dad
I don't think Kings put their own chairs
together I'm sorry to interrupt Zach ran
to the bathroom and he was like Sam can
you cover for me
welcome
right I have literally no idea what to
do just look up placa Flocka yeah
Dan and chat says the chair sucks dude
God I wish I was there well I'll be your
mouth people yeah wait Ian you're
telling the story so much better I don't
understand I'm all these instructions
and [ __ ] I mean somebody somebody help
me for Christ's sake I don't know the
story
except what Ian told me that our
exchange was on Discord I forwarded
everything to Ethan I'm not signing to
my Discord here I don't know if you
inside and just tell just tell me what
you told me okay AB sent me a screenshot
of his conversation with Dad Dad said
that
he wants us to build this chair for him
because he's out of town
and he had some specifications let me
let me find it and then what happened
did you guys refuse the request well
it's ridiculous it would take us like a
significant amount of time here's some
screws this is this is why I'm a little
confused I thought we were actually
gonna build it and give it to you I
thought the [ __ ] talking was just behind
the scenes so that's why I'm a little
and I'm a little off right now
I started putting this chair together
and it was frustrating and uh I was like
look at this and Ethan was like no we
gotta call this guy up
since uh Dan is begging in chat let me
call in he wants to hate and check well
somebody gotta call something you Ian
the story you told me yesterday is so
good and both you guys are giving
nothing me what what is there he gave
instructions to like put the crown on it
and a cup holder and these feet like it
like it's not just put the chair
together which is funny enough it's like
build this chair with all these crazy
specs all right I have the text he sent
to AB
he said sent the chair four feet to
attach the bottom two cup holders in a
crown
cut most of the middle of the chair out
and duct tape the two sides together
oh we on the phone Jessica
Dan please these guys I don't know
what's going on here nobody wants to say
[ __ ]
the super mega guys gave us the chair
dad saw it he got jealous he's like I'm
gonna send a better chair because that
was disrespectful yeah the better chair
that he sends comes in like 15 [ __ ]
boxes it's like he didn't send us a
chair he sent us a chore
and he expected us to put it together it
would take hours I think it said this I
started some beef
[Applause]
and
delivered nothing dad is walking all
over us delivered it right I'm sorry
about your dad passing away that's
defense he's out of town and he wanted
to get you a chair as soon as possible
Lily sorry that sounds [ __ ] great God
sorry yeah no in dance offense he's out
of town he wanted you to have this chair
as quick as possible but yes when we
arrived we were all surprised at how
small it was and that I think it's
fitting all over this podcast right now
why is he out of town and sending the
chair so just wait until you're back in
town and then give the chair it's like
yeah I get it you don't want to build
this [ __ ] neither do we yeah
yeah it's a pain in the ass who wants
the building he better not come back in
town
site now yeah it's on site and you know
also the chair he sent is like tiny it's
not even good like bro this is the [ __ ]
this is a really sad
like twenty dollar chair dad
all right so that's the story thank you
everybody thank you Dan how will you
dance
[ __ ] yeah
so anyway
um
is Seaman ready
I've been artfully wasting time here
no nothing yet okay so see man uh
who who's in contact with her all right
Dan was but he just he cc'd me on the
last message and said I'm gonna send him
the zoom link I sent him the zoom link
and he said he needs another hour I love
c-man like he is the hardest guy to get
on the phone
he gives us the shortest Communications
possible
uh semen he's so [ __ ] busy and he
lives on Reddit
live oh my God should we pull up his
Reddit account
it's not like obscene I mean it is
pretty fun they're all marked not safe
for work it's pretty good I guess I'll
just read the text ones and it's not
obscene it's just interesting
Seaman is another kind
of yeah so Seaman is the foot fetishes I
didn't oh I remember how we found him he
was running ads trying to recruit people
to become footless drivers for him
that's how it all started and then we
had to Fan frame him yes that was a
whole wild Saga and uh Seaman became
beloved to and the fan all of us yeah
yeah yeah I know I know I fell for it me
too
so yeah he's the most elusive of all of
our friends of the show
very hard to contact but this was the
photo we sent him this is Ninja's feet
right
yes to recap hello we were hello we were
on Wiki feet and we're like dude ninjas
how this is like exactly what c-man's
into oh yeah this angle everyone got
never seen anyone photo their feet flops
well actually you're wrong no because he
likes the the
flip-flops oh but he likes it Barefoot
so here's what he said
real quick what's your rating on these
feet we asked he said not bad but he's
wearing flip-flops so I find that a turn
off but it would be hot to see them hit
the pedals hello yes they are hot he's
so specific
I thought he liked it because you kept
talking about the panel I think you're
right but not um
you know on the pedal they should be
they should be bare Barefoot Brothers
driving yeah it's in the yeah the man
it's got to be bare
um when so
when we've been trying to get him to
call in again very short Communications
with them very elusive
he said I'll be in Florida for a foot
worship video shoot
I can come on the show while in the
hotel
what time do you start the show
and then I wanted to obviously ask I got
questions about that in fact
I really wanted to get a cameraman in
there we could find someone in Florida
to follow him around and document that
but I if it was in LA I would have gone
to that I'm sure we can I'm sure we
could have found somebody but I guess
the foot fed worship thing is happening
right now yeah I guess maybe yeah I
haven't heard from him since he said he
needed another hour and that was like
two hours ago shooting right now
probably yeah I think oh he's shooting
something
he said I'll be in Florida for a foot
worship video shoot I think that's
what's happening now and I can come on
the show while I'm in the hotel
maybe he just maybe the
the session went long yeah
if he went he's from New York so you
know you definitely want to imagine the
thrill if you're going down to Florida
for it
do you mind me asking what is it you're
doing down in Florida is it a convention
is just a personal project my and then
he responded my foot worship wrestling
video oh that is in chat and he said I
will go film it for research
for research sounds like he makes it
sound like he's going to beat off to it
is not right when you say for research
it means like for research purposes yeah
it's ironic it's like your dad passing
away
he says my foot worship wrestling video
it will be a fun hot shoot can I click
this what goes on here four foot
worshipwrestling.com
has anyone been to this website yeah
it's behind like a paywall oh um it's
his subscription thing smart good man
just like a dream membership program
yeah
I want to link to his Reddit user can
you one of you guys hook me up yeah
Olivia's looking for her well we're just
waiting for c-man so I'll just try to
give you as much c-man lore as possible
while we wait for him are we just gonna
sit here and wait yeah I haven't heard
anything back from him he said he needed
another hour is that okay I said yes
that's fine I sent him the link and he
didn't respond to that long ago was that
a few hours ago send him another email
all right yeah I sent him two I sent him
two emails one for my email one from Dan
well the email 30 you have is what like
60 messages long or something 67
messages
well regardless this is interesting so
we're just queuing him up so I I still
I'm holding out faith that c-man will
show up
so let's look at his Reddit account
because it is endlessly fascinating in
fact it turns out semen is a pilot
if you can believe that
what do you mean he's has a pilot
license apparently he flies really he's
sucking toes in the air is probably the
ultimate
a little bit of a thrill you know
dangerous
lots of adrenaline there
uh just don't nut on the controls
thank you I'm not gonna open it until
you you can show it it's all just texts
okay
um how do we find his his Reddit user by
the way
I don't know actually he commented on I
see now he commented on an Ela Kleiner
um post on the H3 sub
oh really this website is linked a lot
what does that mean
like he participated in some posts on
our red on our Reddit after he was on
the show I would like he commented and
we were able to confirm because it's
he's linking back to his website his
male footlover one
I just love it's his whole identity the
man loves men male feet period
got the number
one I think he might be so he says
subreddit Brooklyn
uh he posted how was Brooklyn today
oh there's actually people responding
zero upvotes great how was Utah I am not
in Utah I'm in New York
there are approximately 2.5 million feet
in it so you should do all right depends
on how you look at it
boy what did I just click on your post
history
I just asked how Brooklyn is why do you
have to be rude I do not care what
anyone history is true that's kind of
what he said to us you know
so he said he asked that he says here I
flew today out of the Republic Airport
in Long Island it was a nice day that's
it
foreign
that's the post no likes one day was
submitted one day ago so he's very
active yesterday Private Pilot I flew
today out of Republic Airport in Long
Island New York it was a nice day that's
it
why are you why can you be so active on
Reddit but you can't respond to our
emails
you're on here every damn day
I guess you guys need to communicate
this way I wish we had a phone number
for him
here he says oh so this is the Prelude
to our last update three days ago
hopefully flying this weekend
and he wrote out of Republic in New York
Long Island so it happened
and it has zero zero uh comments or
likes
but I'd like to see that chronological
[Applause]
order here
uh very interesting stuff yeah
here he asks in Long Island City how is
this part of the city doing tonight
zero comments uh zero I think Reddit
works like that well he's very active so
is turning it like a Facebook kind of
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah it's
interesting because nobody ever responds
to him but he still does it or almost
like a like Craigslist in a way right
he has his own subreddit Barefoot
Brothers driving and he posts to it but
nobody ever
interacts with it this is four days ago
added more hot driving vids of floppy
socks on my YouTube channel Barefoot
driver for brothers Drive
four days ago zero comments zero likes
um pretty interesting can you pull that
YouTube channel up I'm actually curious
good luck added more hot sock vids zero
comments zero
upvotes
but these are the most interesting here
fly Flight Training Reddit he says this
is oh 18 days ago I fly out of Republic
Airport
and Farmingdale
it's a nice Airport
what is he expecting the conversation to
be like I'm not sure but one person did
respond he says I love it you can fly
there you can fly lots of places
so he had a little action there
um
so that's what's going on here there is
some videos of him sucking on people's
toes and stuff that might be too obscene
I just sent you his floppy socks on Long
Island here take it off the screen for
me Dan September 11th is when oh he's
remembering yeah he's remembering
yeah take it off screen it's awesome so
you let me just show you
have to go way way down
but look at all this this is just from
one month ago he's super active
this video uh is called I suck Derek's
toes as I drive and my rental car in
Tampa Bay This was oh [ __ ] yeah I just
want to show you this real fast it's on
his subreddit uh Barefoot Brothers Drive
yeah so he's driving and he's just he's
just oh my God and it's beautiful
beautiful beach scenery
and he's just stuck in his toe man
and uh it's just a nice it's a nice day
it's a really nice it's a beautiful Foot
hot yeah
no sock
[Music]
s
oh my goodness okay
yeah so there's a lot of kind of stuff
uh
all right let's check out his YouTube
channel see man are you coming
just not he's coming somewhere he's
coming all right he's coming somewhere
we're not here
uh did you pre
oh is Dad here Dad is here so Dad's here
he says you know what I'll fix this I
will build the chair
don't touch that chair I'm doing it I'm
not a lazy dad well
too late I'm sorry about your dad
here I'm gonna send you a couch
you put it together for me
someone Ikea couch yeah
um did you guys vet this Channel or well
just take it off yeah no that that's
fine
it is that videos yeah I just watched
that one okay so this is great this is
um on the one he was promoting
bear brother drivers it's it's very
interesting with the puppy socks like I
wonder why that yeah it's a tease
yeah like a halfway down dress yeah yeah
it is interesting because he doesn't
like sandals oh wait love said don't
watch Love did you get weirder no I said
I said it's age restricted his video
yeah it does
so let's just move on to fantano yet
yeah people want us to talk about that
story
all right well c-man uh I guess the
door's open
would love to know how the foot warship
wrestling wins yeah
he's caught up
a busy man we'll passionately wait until
he
can have some time all right so Drake
versus fantano this is great I mean
obviously I like fantano music of
internet's busiest music nerd
oh that's the guy that fell asleep
and no so let me just break down this
timeline
fantano dropped a video on a second
Channel fantano
titled Drake slid into my DMs
in which he tells a story
showing DMs
he says Anthony it's Drizzy I know we
don't really see eye to eye about my
music and you're not the biggest fan of
mine but it is what it is anyway he gave
him and he sends him a vegan cookie
recipe there's an album of the tweets or
the messages if that's easier in the doc
thank you and when I first heard that I
was like yo Drake that's based as hell
can you believe that like yo I know you
don't like my music but check out this
vegan cookie recipe
like very um
I really appreciate if you could give
this a spin and let me know if it's
worth trying myself appreciate you
Drizzy out
[Laughter]
well it turns out that fantano faked
this these are all fake DMs
but what's very interesting
is that two hours after fantano dropped
this video
Drake
stories this and this is true I went to
Drake's story this is real
Drake [ __ ] sent him a DM
and this is what it said
Your Existence is a light one
and the one is because you are alive and
cause
you somehow wife the black girl
I'm feeling a light to decent one on
your existence
left on red
so actually Drake sent him the super
salty yeah like you're the number one
artist in the world basically in terms
of like popularity and fantano's got you
so bothered apparently fantano's like a
drake hater
constantly giving his music bad reviews
but the fact that Drake
is familiar enough to know the rating
system actually even knows that he's
married to a black girl so clearly has
some familiarity with his personal life
he's so he's obsessed with fantana
and I have to say that Anthony played
this beautifully because
got him I think if he showed this if if
he showed this I would have been like
there's a small chance this is a real
like drag damning or you and talking
[ __ ] like this
he knows the rating system and all that
I would say there's no way this is real
Drake posted this himself
in response to the vegan cookie story
which made him look awesome
yeah no made Drake look awesome oh the
story yeah that's way cooler yeah
dude Anthony got under the skin of Drake
I mean that's just he really did
and so this story started trending
it's still on a story according to cam
it's not been dropped yet eh yep still
up you and Anthony are friends
apparently cam well I to say we're
friends of the stretch but I invited
them to Adult Swim a while ago and have
given him Photoshop stuff too
but he's a nice guy why do you spent the
whole day with him I just like that
picture that's why I dropped it why do
you look photoshopped in dude I don't
know but I can show you another one
don't you agree I I do I think it was
just the quality of the camera but it's
real
I promise if anyone could fake it it's
you I know yeah I know it's tough to uh
prove that but I like your short hair
but I think the long hair suits you know
thank you people have been asking if I
got a haircut but nope
I'm just I'm just uh growing it out to
donate right now so I actually hate
having long hair but oh
Drake by the way has 119 million
followers on Instagram while fantano has
500 000. talk about a signal boost
minutes later it's Drake Drake
uh later revealed that he played 40
chests to get late Drake
to leak it which is so totally did
that's crazy perhaps even 5D uh a
hundred dollars from Dad oh Dad bringing
out the uh the big dollars it was
supposed to be a nice present I'm sorry
my life is crazy at the moment you
deserve a great chair I will give you a
great chair since super mega was so
insensitive I love you and I will make
this right do not build that chair this
is my job to do okay Dad okay I think
you may have been misled on the website
oh don't worry about it eventually which
website whatever website you got the
chair from I always order like stuff oh
yeah yeah
okay Dad I accept I accept wad I'll give
you another chance wad that pack passing
away yeah
yeah we will suspend our judgment yes
yeah Dad W I'm gonna give you another
chance
I'm glad you're doing well though your
life is crazy I hope that it's in a good
way your life is crazy
yeah so fentano tweeted out I made that
man leak his own DMS and it's so true
it's so true how did he know that by
putting out that fake story he's gonna
react with the real DM like that's
pretty like I watched his video about it
yeah
and he was like I just wanted to make a
little
fun goofy video and it's just like a
little inside joke between me and Drake
and maybe he would reach out and say it
was funny or something but like I don't
think he expected him to play himself
that hard that's so funny
and so salty it's like you're Drake bro
yeah that makes me wonder if these
popular traditional media people don't
don't know what it's like like on
YouTube and New Media the trolls is are
it's just so much it's so intense and
it's so [ __ ] bad and so in your face
the people like Drake don't know how to
deal with that [ __ ] because first of all
Anthony is not even a Troll he's not
insulting him personally he's just
judging his music yeah and he can't
handle that to the point of sending DMS
and he's been very complimentary of
Drake in the past 200 past albums I
think it's just honestly never never
mind album but oh the recent one he
didn't like
I saw recently on Tick Tock he said
somebody said Drake is overrated and he
said he agrees so I don't know but who
cares you're Drake bro
you know what I mean
also that's a base take
I agree with that take I yeah I agree I
agree with that too I mean he does have
bobs
but who cares your drink we collabed on
a song Me and Drizzy
oh yeah yeah
great remember holding my fart in
can you play it
this is Drizzy
together
that beat is actually so great
[Music]
hold it hold it hold it don't fart
hold it in
stinky stinky
ten dollars from Angel Ethan you need to
shout out your Tick Tock gifters too how
am I supposed to do that you know I
don't know anything
how am I supposed to shout out my Tick
Tock gifters oh there's I even forgot
you guys were here there's people
putting hats on me and [ __ ] hello
oh so Anthony actually gave a light
eight to this is a Drake album if you're
reading this yeah it came out around uh
dude that's a really good grade for him
that's like solid mark
yeah so he's you know he can't handle it
um
he got on Instagram to explain
how stupid Drake is that is a sorry
State of Affairs that you that you
couldn't bait me in the DMS so you had
to show the whole world you had to show
the whole look look I I messaged him
what is he saying by sharing that look
look I messaged this man in the middle
of the night yesterday to try to pick on
him
how it gets the school yard like it's
school this is not Degrassi this isn't
Degrassi it's not Degrassi it's not too
grassy it's not we're not we're not
playing a high school play we're not
we should both be adults doing and being
adults doing adult things so funny silly
silly silly
all right well you guys are the best
love you love you yes I'm in a lot the
whole video is pretty good he talks
about a lot I I was enjoying it but damn
it's just so interesting that
someone's so [ __ ] famous inside yeah
you can be so bothered Yeah by Anthony
[ __ ] fantano sitting on his private
airplane yes typing Fontana your life
your life is a light one
foreign
oh but wait he called okay now it's
getting a little deeper
fantano retweeted this apparently so now
the beef is intense
on top of everything he's a groomer
here's Drake this is the text your
existence of light one
yada yada and then uh fantana says I
literally just tell people my opinion on
music
Chad Tano
he's a groomer huh this has to do with
the bill the Millie bobby broom
11 whoever she is Billy bobby broom
Billy Bob Thorne um his ex-girlfriend
named Bella they publicly came out as
dating when she was 18 like freshly 18.
this was a few years ago and they had
known each other for for a few years at
least oh so there is another yeah wait
there what's the detail her name is
Bella Harris she's a model and when she
turned 18 like very freshly after that
they announced that they were dating
she's 22 now he's 35. it was in like
2018. why are you doing this bro can't
you just find some of this not like 17
today yeah
the broom
he groomed McBroom
we're actually 16.
yeah [ __ ] trick I don't know about this
one dude yeah you definitely took a fat
[ __ ] L from fantano
brutal huh
and I'll say it again he collapsed with
Chris Brown after he broke up with
Rihanna
[ __ ] that's hard one that one's hard
that's the most like
I don't need to know more you know can I
ask how long after the Chris Brown beat
the [ __ ] out of Rihanna did he collab
with him that I mean let me look
actually not that it matters I think
Chris Brown should be interesting but
like was it right after well supposedly
they got in a fight about Rihanna Drake
and Chris Brown at one point in the club
they got and they had their own beef
um but I'm not sure the timeline exactly
let's see
okay no guidance was in 2019
um the the Chris Brown Rihanna thing
happened like 2010 like a long time ago
and then Brianna Rihanna and Drake had
like a fling through the 2010s kind of
oh I didn't know that they had that song
work together wait I'm confused he Chris
Brown
punched Rihanna so Rihanna and Chris
Brown were dating when they were both
very young yeah and they were coming
home from an event they were in a limo
and he beat Rihanna up there were photos
that surfaced everything he got canceled
blah blah blah then Rihanna continues
with her music career she and Drake
inevitably cross paths they have a
little fling they do like public things
where they're flirting they collab like
people know that there's something
happening and then that ended and then
he came out with a song with Chris Brown
oh what was that a diss to her that's
gross did they have a bad breakup and he
did that to like sister
kind of sounds like it but how can you
date someone and then like you respect
this person you know them intimately
[ __ ] dude
Drake and Rihanna date on and off to
2009 to 2016. dude that's a long time
yeah
I'm not sure that's trashy
agreed
all right well shout out Drake who took
a fat [ __ ] L from fantano This Is The
Stuff of Legends honestly like and also
we've promoted fentano to 120 million of
his fans I mean dubs all around for
fantano obviously like such an owl move
to do
so yeah good job fantano 20D chess right
there
the only other thing is the Jimmy Kimmel
disrespecting but it's 4 30 so I don't
know if we should wrap it up
now or if you want to talk honestly it's
so stupid it is so dumb
really get the I didn't watch it but
just from everything I heard about it
just sounds kind of like it was just
yeah and she was on his show last night
and she like finished her speech okay
yeah so they kind of they made a joke of
it yeah and she also said that like he
gave her her first few spots like on his
show so she she said it was fine but I'm
sure it was annoying so he did a bit
before where they dragged his body out
and they're like oh he's dead and then
somebody was like and the winner of
whatever category this is is uh Quinta
Brunson
and he stays there throughout her
acceptance speech yeah
the thing that these people don't
understand is like
these jokes are written embedded by a
huge Council of people like this isn't
just a Jimmy Kimmel decide trying to
make a statement about her you know what
I mean like he potentially didn't even
write the joke
um but yeah I can see it in like the
writing room like I'll just stay there
then you drag me off afterwards and it's
funny
again I just it's one of those things
that's like
I feel like
I I obviously I don't know him
personally but I feel like I kind of
know him because I used to watch his
late night show for a while and he's
just kind of like silly so I think he
was probably just thinking like to do it
as a goof and looks like it just wasn't
that funny just kind of 100 that didn't
work like you thought probably but the
tweets people were super angry at him if
Quentin brunson's stepping over Jimmy
Kimmel who literally laid in her
spotlight
on the day show on an Emmy isn't a
metaphor for what it means to be a woman
of color in a white man's world I don't
know what it is okay I mean that that's
fine it's more of a poetic
interpretation I get that give me Kimmel
owes Quinta an apology but the messed up
part is every image of her accepting her
award has his ass in it that I think
they didn't think about right but but
you're right that is that is kind of
shitty like look at the photo he just
said dumb ass on the floor but it's
that's true
on the floor it's not like she says in
front of her standing while you're on
the floor well there was I watched the
clip there's pictures of her from the
waist up that you can't I don't think
there's many photos that capture her
whole body like this isn't a good frame
anyway
you see all these idiots in the
background
uh white men are insufferable
that I'll agree with I'll back you up on
that one Quinta Bronson tiller's better
than giving her acceptance speech over
Jimmy Kimmel's dead body
I mean it's not that mean of a every
woman in the background is not amused
Jimmy Kimmel trash
okay now we're talking to me what Jimmy
Kimmel did is worse than Will Smith
what now we're [ __ ] talking hot takes
all right
that's insane dude
that's [ __ ] nuts
that's a hot take
Jimmy Kimmel was also part of the stolen
moment from Moonlight winning
I don't know what that is but apparently
now he has a history of
wait where was they when they read the
wrong way in there yeah
but that wasn't even him was he even on
there yeah was that him I don't think he
read that I think well he's hosting
maybe it was hosting or something like
that but that doesn't mean he had
anything to do with the mistake well
they're they're implying that there's
somehow a conspiracy to ruin people of
colors uh acceptance speeches
maybe they're right Jimmy I don't know
that's you know
interesting uh oh nothing will happen at
Jimmy Kimmel for stealing Quinta
brunson's moment as the first black
woman to win a solo Emmy for writing on
a show anyone who calls this a pattern
of Jimmy's racism will get dragged
despite him doing blackface twice
and using the n-word
can I just say I don't know what to say
but like
I remember watching this clip as a kid
the color Malone one I mean it's pretty
stupid to tan his skin like all black
but I remember watching that and it was
just I didn't even think well you know
what I don't need to defend you yeah
[ __ ] you no block face
we hate that go to hell Jimmy
I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
Jimmy should have
I'm not gonna say anything
okay
what happened
well
I have some thoughts about this but I
don't want to [ __ ] say anything it'd
be there's no black people here so I
don't want to be like the dude who's
saying this about black people without
someone here to tell me if you know to
share their thoughts I should just say
it I'm going to say something I don't I
I probably thank you
Arab world news covered this situation I
sent it if you're interested I guess the
comments weren't that bad though they're
just kind of acknowledging what happened
which was a little corny and awkward
yeah
the only one that was way too [ __ ] uh
hot was this one Jimmy Kimmel is worse
than Will Smith yeah
[Music]
yeah
that's it
I'm going to okay
um
that's about it folks what else is there
to say uh it's Friday baby
uh Julie the HBO podcast saved my life
from unaliving myself
is that possible
is that possible absolutely I mean I
think we see it all the time from fans
they always leave comments like that I
mean I think it's hard for us to picture
it but
we always see comments saying that uh we
help people get through Dark Times
that I that I believe yeah yeah you know
Julie
you owe me your life man you're welcome
it's the least I could do
now thanks for watching we love you
obviously you're the world is better
that you're here yeah
yes yeah stay stay here Mega awesome
nerd said
wait did he say something
no I remembered it's because we moved on
it wasn't the last topic yeah so anyway
um that's about it oh thank you guys
people saying I look like a little snack
uh thank you I'm about to go have a big
old snack did you figure out what you
want for dinner you look because it's 4
30. I have any and you are always the
hang up on this you are the one that
makes this impossible first of all I've
changed so much I've become so easy with
ordering food don't you think no what
because like I feel like it's it's never
even an issue anymore I'm like whatever
the only thing you're happy ordering is
pasta
horrible for me wrong only Italian food
I like is pizza and they have good
salads they have good fish
and chicken
but
we order Mexican so much right but
sometimes you don't eat and that make
and that just ruined yeah right when
you're like when you're like yeah we'll
get whatever you want and then the food
comes and you're like oh I can't even
eat this and you don't touch it that
ruins my meal
because I'm like
I want you to eat right
so so in a sense yes but also
you ruined my meals by not eating
like last night we ordered food that I
felt diff I felt um it wasn't the food
actually
I kind of
okay
got done eating some soup hello fresh
baby hello fresh yeah absolutely we're
also having hellofresh tonight gamer so
seriously you're both doing that that's
awesome oh hell yeah and Olivia you're
living on gamer stuff yeah I'm gonna
drink Gamers up tonight I need help
fresh those pictures look so good
it's awesome my brother came to stay
with us for the week and it was really
simple to just add another person just
for the week another portion yeah that's
so cool
hello Fred
um
thinking of redoing my H3 Gotham Edition
so obviously I'm Batman thank you for
acknowledging that ela's Catwoman that's
what I said cam is Mr Freeze I think I
even requested him to make me Mr Freeze
then too I love Mr Freeze
uh Joker brain Zach of course and then
what is Dan he's Gordon okay that's what
I said
Batgirl Olivia I like that or wait is
that Batgirl because here's back woman
oh there's a bat woman and a bat girl
yeah
the whole family
and then okay so Olivia's bat woman
they're a bat female Lena's bat female
a b is Robin I love that for you
of course Ian is two-faced that's
interesting love is the Riddler and Sam
is poison ivy I like that Ian's two for
a two-faced because of a i n which one
point that oh cool
I love this
this is my fave
and I make a really good Batman look how
I just made that while we were talking
no it's an older one we we talked about
it before but it's been a while I love
my Tick Tock went down did I get banned
again okay hold on it's really
interesting I've essentially been banned
from Twitter
oh yeah I got suspended again bowling
and harassment these stupid ass Tater
[ __ ] bro you guys are so relentless
here I appealed it in a worthless so I'm
just chill again you [ __ ] tater tots
you guys are watching my street all day
it's awesome
Free Speech Instagram looks off too what
happened there
suspended band
when
uh oh
wand
uh thank you thank you everybody
win
so okay hello yeah so but yeah what so
so food I mean Mexican obviously you
have the leftovers from yesterday you
didn't even touch so that's kind of an
issue too
but I've been saving my calories so I'm
looking to go out in a big way tonight
it's a good thing like really fun
something really fun
leftovers yeah
we don't like sushi
I feel like Sushi's so fun yeah we could
try to order sushi the thing is I don't
want to eat rice I'm trying to avoid
carbs just because that little bit of
rice yeah I know it's not gonna it's not
I could eat it I could eat it it's not a
big deal
I'm just trying to keep my blood sugar
really low so I don't get diabetes well
would you guys order if you look into
like
Friday night Burgers you want burgers
brisket
barbecue order barbecue that's good for
my dog
they always have mac and cheese
that's definitely our go-to like fun
thing is there a place you guys like oh
yeah we have a really good spot okay
don't blow up my spot I'll take it back
I'll ask you
was that the place you guys brought me
to yes it is love that [ __ ] was awesome
okay okay okay I'm gonna I gotta wrap
this up guys it's a party
yeah guys have a great great weekend uh
had a lot of fun this week with y'all
another great one
thanks everyone for being here
thank you we will always be here for you
and just remember guys
the world is better with you in it
that's just true
because
there's gotta be it there's got to be
people out there that
whose lives you will touch people who
will miss you
I'm sorry about your dad passing away
yeah really bad
and just also remember this
you never know what's around the corner
yeah and so much can happen in like a
year in two years that's the truth your
whole life can change upside down yep
the more you wait it's like anything can
happen and if I you know by exiting life
early you're removing all the
possibilities of you feeling better
finding happiness Finding hope finding
something to live for it's just it's
right down there you just gotta
stick it out right yeah if you're
feeling like angry or sad or something
like try to just channel that into
I'm gonna like get out of this just to
prove myself prove other people wrong
whatever it is like
or which in my case if you know if you
don't even have the energy to be proving
or you don't care you're too depressed
whatever just stick it out just be sad
be [ __ ] up be depressed but just wait
because something's gonna happen
you know like when you're stuck on a bad
trip you just gotta wait just wait
exactly sometimes life's just a bad trip
and you gotta wait it out right
just wait
okay
the Earth spin
it's a new day
and so what's the worst happens you wait
it out and then you [ __ ] die anyway
so what's the rush
right
I mean look at this kid
yeah Cameron sent it to me by the way no
I I dropped it everyone's gonna be like
to illustrate the fact that I was not
happy and it wasn't popular or anything
in high school and it I'm happy now
everything got better
we still have all those bracelets uh
just one I can't think of a gifted
what's your what's up dude I mean yeah
in college I was so miserable I didn't
think that I would ever be like quote
unquote normal again which doesn't mean
anything really normal but like I never
thought that I could ever be in like a
comfortable stable place ever
actually took so long too before I was
able to
find myself in like a good content Place
uh honestly it took I you know I
remember when I was in it I was like man
you know there's no chance that in a
couple years they're not gonna feel
better it actually took like a decade
dude
but
um
I would have never dreamed that uh so
many good things I would have so many
beautiful things in my life by just
waiting
kids
it's the foot soldiers my beautiful wife
you're um we used to be drug dealers uh
video is probably the most inspiring
video on YouTube in my opinion oh
Cameron it's very good the bell peppers
it's also a good good I love you oh the
wait isn't that is that the same one the
bell pepper yep that's the one that
thinks the same video
Cameron and can I be honest with you
about something yeah I I I didn't like
h3s3 productions for a very long time uh
for political stuff but that video
changed really yeah was it because that
was a reactionary yeah oh that's crazy
was there a video you saw where you like
and [ __ ] this guy
um
yeah I can't remember what though I just
I just didn't [ __ ] with it for a while
but you know I'm not I wasn't OG sorry
that's real interesting
well that's great because I agree
yeah I agree with you
I wonder what it was you know was it
like Jordan Peterson
uh I'll have to go walk down memory lane
and I'll let you know later no yeah
LOL
brah
bro
LMFAO dude
Jordan Peterson's what happens when you
wait too long why
huh
foreign
yeah all right everybody have a great
weekend
God bless or just a mediocre week or
mediocre you know
it is
all right see you guys on Monday oh yeah
don't forget burpees for God
100 a day
burpees for God
all right guys
see you Monday